[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen
[Music]
hey you guys it's wednesday evening
if you hear of sound in the background
it's the ceiling fan tom thought it was
too hot in here so we had to turn the
ceiling fast yeah it was too hot so if
you see like weird dust blowing around
and stuff it's not ghosts
zach baggins it's like oh there's like
little there's [ __ ] orbs
no it's just uh sorry pookie's over
there like playing with one of her
mouses and she's like rolling around
she's [ __ ] funny
all right so uh what are we doing today
we're doing our regular should i wear my
mexican uh shirt
that murder hornet sent to me as a gift
i was gonna wear it today but i forgot i
had i had to uh send it to the laundry
get shrunk
uh maybe i'll wear that in the weekend
we'll see okay well you can wear it
friday yeah maybe i'll wear a friday uh
grandfather's hammer said whose voices
are on the intro i'm not sure actually i
just found them somewhere
um like on one of those so pay free yeah
well yeah they were like the one of
those free sound effects sites or
something and it's just like i kept
scrolling through until i found somebody
saying
words that i wanted and then i just
edited them together yeah it's all
layered in made out of a bunch of stuff
well yeah that's you know that's pretty
much how i did it yeah i just kind of
haven't made a new in a long time
they're almost kind of out of style
people are like man i'm not gonna waste
your time with them intros and outros
you that are saying that because they
can't make them but i have to admit like
all the shows that i watch i skip all
the intros and outros of them of my
favorite youtubers
i don't i don't give a [ __ ]
but uh you know i don't know i'm not
that impatient what's that i'm not that
impatient yeah
i mean i'm pretty impatient but i'm not
that impatient uh it doesn't really
bother me honestly i like i said i watch
ones with
that have intros and don't have intros
we've had the same ones for two years
well i thought about doing another one
but it's just like i just haven't had
time to do it you know what i mean
because it's like it takes a while to do
yeah uh so you know it's i just haven't
had time to do it and it seemed like
kind of low priority
but you know i'll get around to it
eventually probably i was gonna do it
for the new year but you know obviously
that didn't happen
yeah man closing this house it's uh just
draining the money away six hundred
dollars on sprinklers
yeah i'm not trying to go i'm gonna i'm
gonna get the uh the homeowners to pay
for that though during the damn closing
costs
that shouldn't be on us yeah i mean that
was not working yeah and when and they
turned me in and they paid for like a
new dishwasher and stuff because you
know i'm fixing their [ __ ] because i
don't know a place yet right so i kind
of feel like that's that's legit
they have 600 i don't yeah
you know what i mean so and the
sprinklers do need to get fixed all our
grass is going to die yeah it's fixed
so there you go and then we were like
thinking about painting the outside i
found that uh i found the thing with the
paint colors like the ones you can use
and stuff there is a there is a
homeowner's association it turns out
this has an acre of land and by by um
oh it's i think it's an acre out back so
it might be two acres i think that's an
acre over there
and uh according to um
uh florida law that means i could shoot
here if i have a backup
no we're only on three quarters of an
acre is that what it is yeah it's three
quarters of an inch is it okay damn i
thought that was an acre nope it's three
quarters of an acre that's what it says
on zillow that's what it sounds though
yep i thought it was an acre three
quarters because i'm looking at it it
looked like an egg something no it's not
okay um something interesting too when i
was looking at all the paint colors yeah
uh there's they have approved combos
obviously but between the house and the
trim
you also can't have the same color house
as either side neighbors or the house
across the street yeah because they want
them all to look diversified yep
granthar said what's the monthly hoa fee
only 100 it's 100. yeah the internet
comes with it
yeah so it's actually like kind of worth
it yeah um so it's not really that bad
you need to move down here granters
you'd like it here
yeah that means you like certain
sections of it or okay like i said i'm
not a fan of the heat sure kind of
that's the only thing about it
that heat keeps the weaklings out though
calling yankees up north i'm not a
yankee and i still don't like that we'll
take grandpa's though
he can come dj maniacs has just painted
all black i was like you know what i'd
like to but we're not allowed to
honestly most of the approved colors
because we like been walking around the
neighborhood and i was like oh that's
kind of nice so that's kind of nice i
like kind of like the dark gray colors
with like the the lighter trim that
would kill us on his two-story house but
honestly i was like looking up the
approved colors which i think is
sherwin-williams by the way and uh the
only one that i thought was like okay of
the ones that you could have
was moth wing that was the name of it it
was kind of like a dark
almost kind of like brownie stone kind
of color and you could then have that
and then you could have kind of like an
off-white trim that was kind of nice
like a sort of grayish trim it's got to
prove colors the closest thing to all
black is they have a gray one yeah like
a dark gray but um it looks good there's
a couple houses that are like that the
problem is this is a two-story house and
it will cook you and you'll be spending
all kinds of money on air conditioning
in the summer
it's just you know it's rough yeah
that's why i mean i don't really like
the color it is now i can't i'm trying
to figure out which color because i was
looking at all the colors
it's kind of like a whitish like an off
weight but then the trim is also kind of
white so it just looks like this big
yeah it's got to be really it needs like
contrasting colors yeah you know what
i'm saying like to look better because
it just looks like a big white box needs
to have like a chocolate like a
chocolate brown well that's kind of what
like what that moth wing color is but
it's not quite it's not quite brown it's
kind of like a like a warmish gray but
it's pretty dark that's a little
trending toward brown you know if that
makes any sense yeah and you can have
that with like a kind of an off-white
trim and that look that seemed like it
looked pretty nice i don't like any of
that yellow [ __ ] yeah because there's
like a lot of a lot of the houses in
here that you know that are more like
they're mediterranean-looking so they're
kind of like that golden rod kind of
color
which
looks okay on some of the houses but i'm
not a fan of like yellowish there's
actually the house is a mix the houses
are a mix
they're southern kind of english
colonial houses that there's one
expensive one that's all brick that's
like that
the rest of them are kind of like
baroque kind of spanish
and other ones are modern but they're
definitely out of the same catalog these
houses all came out of the exact same
catalog and the original people that
moved in here ordered them at how they
wanted them depending on what they want
they're they're different prices
they look good
um they're just
you could tell they're out of catalog
well everything is every neighborhood is
like that yeah because that's what they
do they sell a lot and then they have
like this big thing and they're like we
have x amount of floor plans they
usually have a name and it's a special
company that is approved to come in here
and build and then you pay extras if you
want i'm pretty sure they do that
everywhere yeah i mean like i said i
used to do ads for this got a nice big
lake
you can get in it never had to grow
kayaking they allow you to fish in it i
haven't fished in it yet
some of the deluxe houses they're backed
up against that lake they have their own
map their own little landings with the
boats and [ __ ] yeah
um this is not one of the deluxe ones
this is like this this is one of the
low-end two-story houses which puts it
in the [ __ ] middle range
because there's a lot of single-story
houses in here they look nice but
they're not they're half the price of
this house
yeah i mean i don't know if i'd go
halfway but they're
because this is 475 000. those are 200
maybe 30 000
250 maybe
yeah i'm not sure what the what the
they're not very square footage they're
not big a lot of them
there's different ones but the ones i'm
talking about i don't think you've seen
them yet they're there on that other
street you know when you first come in
and turn left yeah that block has all
the little houses
yeah we drove down there one okay like a
couple of times i think we're like
they're like half the size of the house
that we moved out of
yeah okay they're smaller than that
that's well i mean the house we moved
out it wasn't that small
but they're half that size but yeah so
that's small yeah
yeah i guess like the smaller ones are
kind of like along the front like
towards them yeah
because you're getting i get maybe
because you're getting trapped while i
was gonna say you get traffic noise
because that's where the main road is
but you're not gonna get much traffic
noise because there's not much traffic
on that road no
that's just i can't remember what that's
what county road that is but uh yeah so
yeah so they're talking about uh
different building codes and stuff like
that attic fans all that kind of stuff
but yeah i'll show you the the list of
all the colors they have a little matrix
of
how of like a big list of colors you can
paint your house and then there's like a
little matrix you go across and it
matches up like what trim you can use
you know what i mean but like i said you
can't do it the same color
as the houses on either side of you or
the house across the street from you
this doesn't have attic fans we all have
ceiling fans here
there aren't any attics really
we do have kind of like an attic space
but it's not like an attic ad you can't
go in it you can't really go in there
you can like floor right which is it's
just insulation and it was just that's
kind of like our old house was like that
too there was like a little thing in the
ceiling in the garage and you could kind
of go up in there but it wasn't really
we had some [ __ ] there yeah we had some
[ __ ] stored in there but it was like
pretty small that's like where the
christmas tree was and all that kind of
[ __ ] yeah i put boards in there and
would climb up in there and that's where
i had a lot of christmas tree stuff yeah
and this one has we didn't actually
think this had an attic that's uh the
the entrance is right here in this
closet like in my dressing room
and uh we thought you couldn't go up
there but yeah you can the inspector
went up in there and we were like well
i'll be damned
i went up in here you can stand up in it
really yeah stand up in it so it's kind
of like the old house thing yeah a
little bit higher
ceilings a little bit higher it's pretty
big i was like that damn
i can store it in there
okay you can store in there you just
have to support it out in and out of
it's a [ __ ] it doesn't have its own
staircase to get into it
yeah you have to yeah it doesn't even
have like a full down like our old house
had the fold down ladder this one
doesn't even have that you have to get
your own ladder go in the car it was a
staircase yeah there's a staircase on
the back of that door remember
no it wasn't it wasn't a ladder a ladder
is different it has steps
it was a staircase
yeah but i mean it was a ladder that was
like slanted like a staircase yeah but
it has
it it was ladder has rungs you grab onto
with your hands well you cannot grab
onto with your hands
yeah i'm just saying it seemed more like
but it was a ladder like it was a
foldable staircase yeah not a ladder
this one does this one does not have
that so you have to take your own ladder
into the closet
and climb up in there which i'm not
gonna be doing anytime soon that's for
sure
camp guy said my house now has a big
whole house fan that sucks air down the
main hallway and out the top of the
hallway into that into the attic and out
of the house yeah i think a lot of
houses have that grandfather's hammer
said house inspectors have a sweet gig
500 for a couple hours yes they do yes
yeah i observed that
i observed that come in and expect
although our guy was good he
gave us some ammunition you know let us
look you know something to negotiate
with and then uh yeah he was in here was
three hours he was here three hours i
think and then reassured me that some of
the stuff that i was seeing was not
structural
you know house needs a little bit of
work but i'm not worried about it just
over time we'll be able to take care of
it we're going to start off with
landscaping i mean being house inspector
i think to do that what do you need to
do like take a take a course or
something because you do have to know a
little bit about like electrical [ __ ]
and plumbing and stuff like that
but i don't think you have to be an
expert expert but you just have to know
when there's something that matters
so you do have to have a good general
knowledge of construction and stuff i'm
sure that would help but
yeah i mean other than that yeah they
just kind of like crawl around and your
[ __ ] they were crawling around into the
sink and up in the attic and everything
and you know was it yeah it was 500
right yeah he was here for three hours
so how long you been talking uh
18 minutes well 20 minutes yeah yeah
well not really because we were on so
it's more like 15 minutes
because we had the thing on
sheila anne said i imagine addicts in
florida would be intolerable oh no yeah
i kind of feel like i don't really see
we don't really have basements either um
i've seen houses with basements older
ones but the basements are usually like
half
underground and half
but like i lived in a house like my
grandfather's old house which has since
been torn down which i think was built
in the
early 20th century
had a basement
but it was like half above ground and
half underground and it was like kind of
small it wasn't like a big huge because
i know up north they have like this big
huge basements and a lot of people like
finish them out like to make rec rooms
and stuff um people don't really do that
here so much
honestly the water table in florida
um
it's you're just like asking for trouble
if you have a basement it's gonna flood
at some point unless you're like way up
on a hill or something which you don't
really get a lot so i just don't have
them here they don't yeah like i said
i've seen ones with them but it's very
uncommon it's very uncommon and if they
do have them they're not that far
underground because it would flood some
of these ultra modern
mansions
might have kind of subterranean floors
but they're on a hill usually yeah and
then there's like a deck that comes out
there might be swimming pools back there
and then half of it's in a damn hill and
it goes up another two or three stories
sometimes yeah i've seen stuff like that
yeah they have all kinds of ultra modern
[ __ ] here but i mean if you
because honestly most of florida we have
like little hills and [ __ ] but most of
flora is at sea level yeah so you dig
down a few feet and there's water
so like i said you're kind of like
asking for it
you go out here
oh you got here in the back of this uh
reserve
you uh you hit the edge of it and look
out it's just cow pastures it looks like
something out of damn wyoming kind of
cow pastures and
yeah it's crazy looking
it's a lot of empty it looks like you're
out in the middle of nowhere but you
can't go very far in a single direction
before you hit a road or a town
but it's
the density here is not very
dense you know
and there's still a lot of
uh nature i don't know how you say nato
raisa in [ __ ] english nothing is a
wildlife
natural scenery i guess
it's like you're in the country you're
not really though
yeah i mean more of an illusion
well yeah and when we started like
walking around the neighborhood like a
few days ago and
it's just funny how this neighborhood
like
which is pretty big and it butts up
against
yeah like it looks like [ __ ] kansas
it's not yeah it's just like this big
huge
open like cattle
thing cattle ranch yeah there's cows out
there and [ __ ] and i was like huh like
right across the street from some of the
houses in the neighborhood there's like
a big [ __ ] expanse of of cattle it
looks like you can shoot around here i
want to shoot i hear people shooting i
hear people shooting i don't know where
they're going but i got [ __ ] i got a
zombie ask around i gotta zero some [ __ ]
ask some of the neighbors because i hear
people shooting around here i don't know
where it's at but
you know
it's you know i inherited an old high
point carbine remember the old high
point carbines grab theirs i'm [ __ ]
going to turn that [ __ ] into something
that's actually makes sense get rid i
got a rid of a lot of [ __ ] on there
it's just going to have a red dot sight
it'd be real sleek no
no mechanical sights on it and just
[ __ ] trim down threw all those
[ __ ] stupid ass rails off the [ __ ]
thing it's just going to be super
trimmed down and minimalist kind of like
the first one it's about halfway there
that's good but i got to get it came
with weaver rails and i got to get
[ __ ] um
uh what's in that we've
[ __ ]
weavers with the old ones the new rails
are [ __ ] um
you know what i'm talking about the new
rail system i forgot what it's called
go ahead grab this hammer said my
basement is a man cave bar and prepper
room yeah okay there you go yeah uh
thank you no need for me too yeah uh
saying my 69 mustang is coming along
beautifully gonna try and send stuff
off next week to you guys thank you very
much happy new years to chat yeah happy
new year to everybody in case we haven't
wished you guys happy new year yet uh we
have done a couple shows since then but
this is kind of like the main show since
then
and uh you know yeah camp guy's saying
we have to keep dehumidifiers in our
basement in the summer feels cooler than
air conditioning
yeah i kind of feel well that's sort of
why we run the air all the time although
it doesn't run as much here as it did at
the old house old house it pretty much
ran like uh
all the time but continues that's what
it's called picatinny ribs i gotta swap
that out to get a picatinny on there so
i could put it put that i got i got red
dots everywhere old ones i'm gonna put a
whole red dot on there
it doesn't have shake awakes so
i got some of those that don't have
shake awake that i got i got to put on
there because i can you can't run those
on ars anymore i got
my phone's right oh your phone okay yeah
that ghostly ass music was coming i
thought well yeah that's what it's
called coming to get me i had it no i
had a um i downloaded an app that has
like all kind of like horror like and
scary music like for ringtones and stuff
because i'm weird like that
but that's yeah that's the ringtone it's
like i don't know it's i don't know why
i bothered because i never
nobody calls me and when they do i don't
answer it so whoever lived here before
was uh at one time or another was a
reloader or maybe not a reloader but a
shooter because inside the dam all the
flower beds
and
not only is there mulch in there dude
threw his brass in there there's
thousands and thousands of rounds of
nine millimeter and five five six brass
in there and all you gotta do is [ __ ]
get it and tumble it and you can reload
it which i'm thinking about doing
a lot there's a lot of 38 special there
and some of this shit's nickel
camp guy says cheap fun hobby bought
four or five nice bird feeders and
mounted outside my window 200 bucks plus
feed to put inside them i've thought
about doing that for like hummingbirds
or uh you know what i've always wanted
to do build a bat box yeah i want to
like build a little box for like for you
some bats to live in so they eat all the
mosquitoes you feed birds here you can't
get rid of them yeah that's true so
maybe it was like
bats would probably be better to be
honest although
because at least they but well i guess
birds do too
you know let's we used to see
hummingbirds sometimes around our old
house just around some of the plants in
the front
i don't know why they put the brass in
the flower boxes but i gotta get now i'm
gonna get it all out
somebody who didn't reload
doesn't make any damn sense yeah i was
sold that there's all kinds of guys that
bought maybe it was done at a time where
they didn't do it but it's all black but
you can tumble it
tumbling it's not a big deal
all right so
are you ready to like get the topic
started or not
now
this is funny because
before he started the show and tom's
like what's the show about again yeah
and i said it's about the lindbergh
kidnapping oh yeah i know about that and
then he proceeds to talk about this case
that i have no [ __ ] idea i'm like no
that's not what we're talking about but
okay i don't even know what you were
talking about another case of these two
like gay guys in their teens and early
20s
took some
captured some kid little kid and then
they
they held him for ransom but it didn't
work out and then and the older one
killed the kid
and then the younger one got blamed for
it i don't know if that was in the
united states though
um
and that was about that time early 1900s
maybe 20s 30s
that's the way i remembered it
well that's a completely different case
than what we're talking about today i
remember what case that was
i don't even it sounds kind of familiar
but i don't really like offhand i don't
really know what you're talking about so
i'd have to look it up
but
i mean ransom kidnappings i feel like
and i was watching something earlier
um
that
i mean ransom kidnappings are pretty
much
i don't know if i'd say non-existent but
they're very very rare nowadays yeah
mostly
yeah well kidnappings nowadays that's
mostly well the overwhelming number are
uh
one parent kidnapping the kid like in
custody disputes says that's the
overwhelming number and then you get
ones that are like you know obviously
pedos
that's the second category but uh you
know ransom not so much you don't really
see it
you don't really see it that much
anymore too complicated it can go too
wrong it costs a lot of money it takes
too much time it's just there's other
ways
to steal money
it's just not popular no they'll do it
in central and south america
but i don't know
they don't do it they don't do it up
here that's a that's a retro [ __ ]
yeah it seemed like it happened a lot
like back in the day
but you don't really see it anymore not
in the united states or europe as far as
i'm aware like i said i'm sure it's not
non-existent but it just doesn't like
you said there's there's other ways of
yeah making a lot of money in a short
like if you're going to go the illegal
route you go in otherwise because it
would be much easier most states have a
[ __ ] life sentence for kidnapping so
why the hell would you want which um
actually this case was the one that
brought in like all those they call it
lindbergh law that's what he's called uh
that made kidnapping essentially a
federal offense which it wasn't prior to
this but that's this is the case that
yeah and why would you want to go
through all that problem when you can do
a note job on a bank and then you're
facing federal time which would be a lot
sweeter than state time
and as long as it's a note job it's not
really armed robbery so most they'll
give you 10 years probably yeah but a
first offender they might give you only
give you five
and then by the time you fail guilty and
everything that's two or three years
into it so you only do another two years
and then you're out so really the the
risk versus reward is a big factor in
why certain crimes are popular like it's
ridiculous man in brazil and parts of
central and south america they still
have [ __ ] old-fashioned crimes that
nobody worries about here like over
there they'll carjack a car to steal it
and then resell it
man you can't make any money [ __ ]
still selling stolen cars in the united
states
yeah i kind of feel like that's sort of
like gone down the hill i mean like i
said it's i'm sure it happens but
i feel like most people if they're going
to steal a car they steal it in in
service of like
another crime that they're committing
they use it as a getaway vehicle right
and then they [ __ ] burn that and then
burn it right in brazil they're so poor
oh my god you know we've stolen a car
i'll sell you this car for a [ __ ] 5
000 and then they try to give like a
fake license plates or something you
know
and that's just like that's people who
are desperate for cars all right well
yeah the way it is i mean the same thing
is like when people like you know would
break into your house and like steal tvs
and vcrs and [ __ ] back in the old days i
kind of want a tv yeah like nowadays
everybody's like who the [ __ ] wants that
nobody i think i kind of feel like the
only people doing that are maybe like
really desperate like drug addicts that
like need a little bit of money for
trump the only reason why they'd ever
steal a car in the united states it'd be
some popular tuner car like a honda like
one of these honda civics and they're
gonna steal this honda civic because
it's modified and they take it to a chop
shop and they take all the [ __ ] turbo
chargers and all the accessories and
everything that that dude put on there
and
certain you know certain parts that are
worth a lot of money and they'll sell
those you know [ __ ] second hand or
over the internet they don't want the
car they want the parts off the car yeah
that's what granthar's hammer was just
saying yeah detroit has 20 carjackings a
day some get torched some get stripped
for birds yeah parts yeah you're not
really reselling the whole entire car
now in brazil they'll try to resell the
whole car yeah
yeah that's a cultural it's a cultural
cultural thing
uh high desert004 says uh the case you
were talking about is leopold and loeb
yes yeah which which was a very famous
case we should actually do a show about
that one of these things i'm crazy thank
you for backing no i didn't say that you
say you were crazy i just said i said i
know that's a real case i just couldn't
think of what it was uh but i said it
doesn't have anything i think it was in
the 20s wasn't it i think it was you
said 20s or 30s uh i can't i actually
can't remember when that was right
weren't they i thought they were
brothers were they not i thought they
were i can't remember it's been it's
been a long time
uh also and i'm gonna get into this uh
but i like that you brought this up so
hi desert also says have you heard the
theory that the lindbergh did away with
their kid themselves because the kid was
disabled and lindbergh was into those
nazi eugenics theories yes i have heard
that theory and i am going to get uh
into that as well graeme granville who's
the heck in case you guys are new to the
show he's the next uh he's a retired
policeman that i went to school with
um we grew up together he's saying what
they want is they just want the rims the
airbags and the catalytic converters
thank you that's right
the cats are worth money because you got
to pass [ __ ] emissions
and they don't want to pay to pay retail
and the [ __ ] airbags they want those
and ramps aftermarket or stock or
aftermarket it doesn't matter they want
those rims the rest of the car they'll
just [ __ ] throw it away or torch it
they just don't give a [ __ ]
it's
it's well it's not worth it it's not
worth it to them
yeah it's just you know i was for some
reason i was thinking of like those
people
well i was for some reason i was
thinking of like those people that go
into like buildings that are about to be
torn down and to like strip out all the
copper because that's like the only
thing that's worth anything yeah like
that's left in there if you stripped a
if you stripped a [ __ ] honda civic
and only took those parts off of it and
if a brazilian [ __ ]
car thief saw that they'd have a [ __ ]
heart attack they'd want every bit of
that damn car
every bit of it but like i said that's
it's a cultural difference too i mean
obviously it's like a much bigger deal
well i think they're more poor they're a
lot yeah and they're scrambling for more
money
i mean here like consumer goods are just
so they're so cheap
yeah um
100 import tax in brazil
yeah 100 import tax so everything's
twice the price
because the brazilian government's job
is to steal basically it doesn't produce
anything it just steals
totally illegitimate
high desert says anyone try to steal a
tesla yet oh i'm sure
i haven't heard about it but
i'm sure somebody has although i always
thought it would be really dumb
to steal a car that was
kind of rare or
high you know no they steal those no i'm
just saying no i'm saying here i'm not
staying there no they steal them here
ferraris lamborghinis teslas they steal
all that the thing is is that they're
not resold in the united states
they're smuggled away they're put up
there they're they're hidden and they're
put on ships and they're sent to the
middle east where they're sold [ __ ]
used in places like dubai and saudi
arabia well that's huge
but only luxury cars
well that like i said that makes sense
and that and for that you would need
like a big like a criminal conglomerate
because
yeah operation and i'm just talking
about like just regular ass cars yes
in that gig right there
um middle eastern governments are
involved they know all about it they
facilitate it because they want those
cars they don't care that they were
stolen from other countries they don't
give a [ __ ] they
those well they probably feel like yeah
they're insured
they're insured
we want that brand new lambo we want it
here for half the price and if you can
afford a lambo you can afford to buy
another lambo yeah to be fair so yeah
you know that's probably going to
justify it
and honestly if somebody can afford a
lambo i'm not going to feel too bad if
it gets stolen i'm not saying it's right
i'm just saying i don't feel that you're
insured yeah that's what i'm saying and
evidently that operation involves trucks
they put it into a truck and hide it and
drive it that kind of thing uh [ __ ]
helicopters and ships and
[ __ ] you know
import agencies and stuff that have been
bribed to get that thing through
inspections and they'll hide it inside
[ __ ] grain grade containers and [ __ ]
and then in there will be stolen [ __ ]
high-end cars
bound for some saudi arabian prince
yeah yeah
well actually probably not some prince
because he can afford a new one it's uh
yeah that's what i'm saying some like
second or third rate saudi arabian rich
guy some kind of like upwardly mobile
that wants to like he wants show off but
he can't quite afford it exactly you
know what i mean so he has to get a
little bit of a knock off kind of well
not a knockoff but one that's like a
little bit cheap discount you know
yeah cause like you said some [ __ ]
big ass like billionaire now they got
he's just getting new but he's like i
got a whole garage full of new ones i
don't need like some
criminal conglomerate overseas
slasher fred says if you guys ever watch
uh murder on the orient express the
motive for the murder which is the
kidnapping and murder of the young
infant is an homage to the lindbergh
kidnapping this was i kind of feel like
the lindbergh kidnapping
was
a [ __ ]
media
circus
it was just like all over the [ __ ]
world i mean this is the 1930s they were
called the crime of the century the
trial of the century was like a huge
[ __ ] deal and i think that it was
like
this was probably the biggest deal
as in everybody following like every
[ __ ] you know minutiae of the case
probably up until
the jfk assassination i don't even think
i can't think of anything
in the interim that was quite as big as
this i mean this was a massive [ __ ]
deal because you have to think like
charles lindbergh
uh in
you know he was world famous i mean he
was like probably arguably
one i mean easily one of the most famous
americans at the time
um and he was known worldwide so the
fact that his kid got kidnapped uh was a
massive massive deal
so
you know uh as i said even back then you
can like look up the newspapers from
back then crime of the century it's like
this big huge [ __ ] thing i mean you
know it's like it's a really sad case
but
as i said we'll kind of get into
what happened and then we'll get into
some of the other like
alternative theories we'll call it that
and this one
i'm not sure uh i'm not sure about i
mean i i have my i have my
the way that i'm leaning toward this
some of the kind of like weird none of
the theories in this are crazy you know
what i'm saying um they're all like
plausible
but
i still have i still have like one
particular way that i'm leaning
and i watched a few other documentaries
about this there was one on pbs it was
on nova there was a you know there's
been a couple of others on the history
channel there was like some other ones
and most of the like experts and stuff
kind of were lean in the same way i was
leaning so i was like okay well that
makes me feel better um but as i said
this one doesn't have like any of these
like wacky
conspiracy theories type things like it
was aliens or was the illuminati or it
was nothing like that uh pretty much
every theory about it is somewhat
plausible
so uh all right so are you ready to get
into it go ahead and go now when i start
talking about this maybe you'll remember
it okay
but we should do we should do leopold
and loeb though write that down because
i think i remember that well somebody
recommended that to me and i said oh
that's a good idea and i think i put it
in the poll one time but it didn't win
but
i'm always looking for more stuff to put
in the poll because
i'm running out of topics i mean i'm
sure i'm not running out of topics but
it's just
i mean there's so much [ __ ] to talk
about but
i just i can't think of it like when i'm
trying to do the [ __ ] polls and i'm
just kind of like well and i try to like
mix up let's do like supernatural or
let's do true crime let's do this then
the other thing i'm actually surprised i
put this in the poll like several times
and it hasn't won but it won this time
so uh i've been wanted to do this one
for a while i knew about it but i didn't
know like all the particulars so i've
actually had a good time like over the
past three past two or three days like
reading a bunch of stuff about this
watching a bunch of documentaries about
it like still you know looking at other
people's like takes on it and stuff like
that it's really interesting
so charles lindbergh uh in case you're
not from the united states uh or you're
really young and you don't know who this
dude was
a massive massive celebrity back in the
1920s now in 1927 charles lindbergh was
the first person to fly solo across the
atlantic ocean without making a stop he
flew from new york to paris so back in
those days in the early days of aviation
uh
that was a like a massive deal and
everybody was like hanging on every
single like thing that he did just so
much same thing one like amelia earhart
got really famous all these kind of like
aviators got really famous and uh he was
one of them
he had like there were songs written
about him he had like all kind of it was
just like a big huge thing
now
in when his kid was taken this was early
1930s now he became
let's call this a little bit of a
controversial figure later on uh which
uh one of y'all in the chat like brought
up a little bit
but
which i'll get into because it does
actually factor into one of the theories
about the crime
but you know still when the when the
crime happened it was only like a few
years after his like historic
uh flight so everyone was still kind of
like he's is there a male equivalent of
america's sweetheart there's not is
there a male equivalent of america
i don't know why i just thought of that
but it's just like i thought he was
america's sweetheart i'm like well
i mean i guess sweetheart isn't really
gendered but
that's usually justin bieber
that's usually used to refer to like a
girl or a woman you know like shirley
temple or something so it's like i'm not
really sure if charles lindbergh never
struck me as a sweetheart type of guy he
seemed like
i don't know he he seemed like kind of i
didn't he was an aviator right yeah dad
charles lindbergh yeah yeah yeah he flew
across the atlantic the first person to
fly solo across the atlantic ocean yeah
also a nazi that's what i was gonna get
into um
i've read some of his uh views about
race and eugenics and stuff like that he
kind of does that like a nazi and
honestly um
after the kidnapping and after all the
publicity around the crime like him and
his wife like went to
europe and kind of like cozied up a
little bit with the you know so you know
oh yeah also kind of friends with henry
ford who was very uh
big anti-semite so you had a lot of that
kind of stuff going on that was a
universal
thing though back in those days it was
um
well not really because he kind of got
called out for it at the time yeah not
everybody liked it it's just that that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] uh widespread a lot of
people were doing that yeah not excusing
it a lot of people were doing it no it's
just the way the world was back then
[ __ ] and even in japan you know i
mean
i guess you could say cultural and
racial supremacy was um a thing
pretty much for for everybody in general
yeah yeah it was definitely an idea that
was an idea
it wasn't like just a a white boy thing
[ __ ] all the other races were kind of
thinking along those same lines too
because they were looking at they were
interpreting what they were interpreting
the writings of darwin
in a way that they wanted to interpret
it
yeah well we got this [ __ ] done that's
because we got selected
we were selected for survival by so
we're obviously better
yeah and well no lindbergh kind of had
that like from like i said from some
stuff that i've read that he's said and
like written and stuff he definitely did
seem like because i feel like this is
kind of a lot of people that are into
like nazi [ __ ] or like eugenic [ __ ] it's
always kind of like well obviously i'm a
part of the superior race yeah i know
about you [ __ ] you know what i
mean and he definitely did have a little
bit of that a little bit of that
attitude though is that they always want
to interpret history the way they want
to interpret it well they kind of have
an erroneous interpretation of of what
happened in the past
yes like it didn't quite go like for
instance the whole idea of the indian
genocide was a white supremacy idea
the indians are gone because we're
better than them we won it's not how
that happened
okay a lot of it had to do with
integration too
and also just waves and waves of [ __ ]
immigration from europe just you know
over just overwhelmed them just in
numbers and then situation changed
well there was a lot of factors too many
factors happen you know industrial
revolution had a lot to do hardly
anything on that grand of a scale is one
reason no yes it's always a bunch of
interlocking and there was pandemic also
sure [ __ ] you know indians died from
pandemic
in the 1500s which reduced the numbers
so it's always more than one thing so
the selection isn't always just based
upon you and what you do the selection
is also just based upon things that are
far outside the control of people
yeah because well and that's another
thing too is that humans tend to like
overstate their own importance yeah it's
like most [ __ ] that happens is out of
one is out of an individual's control
yeah the dinosaurs were selected for
extinction
that has nothing to do with the
dinosaurs it had a lot to do with
[ __ ] meteor impacts well yeah okay
and and climate change over time and we
and if we had been around back then we
would have just been standing there
going well [ __ ] we're good we would have
done the same thing even though uh
there's this idea that the dinosaurs all
died at once
the impact happened a lot of them
survived they died slowly over a period
of about a million years
yeah they didn't all die right away
right it's a slow process you don't
notice it when you're there well it's
easy to look back and i would just
before we get too much into this uh
thank you aaron
uh for the super chat can't stay long
but i like saving you both uh to keep me
sane during the work day oh thank you
just wanted to stop in and say happy new
year happy new year to you as well and
thank you very much
but yeah so like everything else
everything is very complicated and
it when particularly when you look back
at history um
it's very easy from you know because
human lifespans are relatively short
so when you look back and like think of
like all this stuff that happened over
this period of time like like you said
like the dinosaurs look it'll be
non-controversial because we're not
talking about humans uh we're talking
about like the dinosaurs dying it's like
it's almost like the way it's portrayed
not if you take an actual science class
but when uh the way it's portrayed it's
like oh the the meteor hit the earth and
then the dinosaurs died it's like yeah
but it took a really long time millions
i mean obviously
and now obviously not everything died
because
we're still here uh because we evolved
from what was left over back then like
all the little bitty little mousy
creatures that were running underneath
the dinosaur's feet so in a lot of ways
that meteor was kind of the only reason
that we're here because we would not
have evolved alongside dinosaurs
because they were like the apex
predators so
it's uh but yeah it took a really long
time it's you know obviously a lot of
animals were killed in the impact right
but it was more like the repercussions
it was more like the repercussions of
the impact and it took a long long time
that's it the same kind of things happen
with humans
so um
the the the problem with
with the with the with the human with
the nazis concept of eugenics and then
not just the nazis other people were
also guilty of the same assumption
is they always thought
that their success right now was because
of them
and what had happened like kind of
recently most of the reasons why they
were successful
didn't have a whole lot to do with their
with them specifically it had to do with
like
other factors yeah that they didn't
control right a lot of it is just
geography
oh big time where you are on the planet
at any given time
uh at any stage of societal development
well if you look right now because of
the internet a world culture is kind of
forming everyone is catching up with
each other the
disparities between continents is kind
of slowly eroding
and it's because of the free trade of
information so that's a new factor that
has never been thought of before so we
don't really know what the impact the
long-term impact is going to be i don't
think anyone can predict that
it's too complex too complicated for our
pitiful brains and yeah people are being
selected for extinction but it's
individual people
if you're an [ __ ] you get killed
because the cops kill you or you go to
prison you can't enough children
over time that's has an effect
everywhere everyone everywhere is slowly
kind of becoming the same
because
systems are
doing their job is that's a good way to
put it
so the differences aren't so much racial
they're more just kind of like the
difference or more um
uh
what what's cis now i want to say
systemic that can be re the the
differences are
are uh
what do you call it
not even culture
institutional
that's a good way to put it yeah
certain places didn't have institutions
you know like
i mean or law enforcement and the thing
about it too is just kind of like that's
kind of like
and that's kind of goes back to what we
talk about like for example when we talk
about serial killers where we're talking
about oh it's environment it's genetics
and stuff like that and some of it might
very well be environment because
honestly if you grew up in a family that
lived on some land that was like [ __ ]
polluted like with some industrial
runoff and then you had parents that
didn't give a [ __ ] about sending you to
school and you all this all this other
stuff it's like that would be you would
be
that it would be much harder for you to
overcome all of that uh especially
because there are a lot of other people
who didn't have to overcome all of that
so they started like much further along
than you did
so it's not impossible but it's like
much much more difficult we talked about
it before
a lot of this weird [ __ ] the serial
killers were doing in the 70s it's not
as common as it used to be
but a lot of it was happening during the
70s and it was happening in places that
were
collapsing metropolitan areas
cities that were collapsing because the
the economy wasn't there
also there was a leaded gasoline which i
think was a factor
yeah and like i said you're not the only
person that said that i've seen that in
other things too and i definitely think
i don't think that's the only factor but
i think that's probably a significant
factor some people go like well why
would a collapsing city have anything to
do with serial killing because you can
get away with it there
yeah you can get away with it there
there isn't any there's an environmental
factor matter of fact we talked about
that when we were talking about that the
canadian city like those three cities
where all those serial killers were
operating southern california it just
has to do not only with
uh you know genetic factors for the
individual which i'm sure is a factor
also but it also has to do with
environmental factors if you're a serial
killer if you have that proclivity
you're gonna go somewhere where you
think you're gonna get away with it for
as long a period as possible even if
you're not like really thinking of it or
you will arise up out of the more ass
yeah because it's your existence is
allowed if the same dude is in a more
developed area he's caught early so he
never and he never becomes a serial
killer because they catch him like after
he's they catch him setting little
kittens on fire and [ __ ] yeah and then
[ __ ] like that right we just get you
better not [ __ ] that kid yeah don't
do [ __ ] with the cats don't [ __ ] with
cats i'm just saying right now i'm gonna
keep
i lived in detroit also for [ __ ] a
year and a half and used a cop in that
area
weird [ __ ] will happen in detroit that
could only happen in detroit it's
probably better now because detroit is
mostly gone i was there when before they
tore most of it down it was like
something out of a damn post-apocalyptic
movie it was amazing i lived on
i was uh on second and second and west
hancock right offside right off from
[ __ ] cast corridor i had a lot of fun
there
you know but i stand out of trouble but
man it was [ __ ]
it was like i said post-apocalyptic you
come out of the damn apartments [ __ ]
in the morning wake up maybe some black
dudes [ __ ] feet coming up out of a
[ __ ] dumpster frozen's rock solid
because they [ __ ] killed him and
threw him in a damn dumpster
and it was just like normal
it was [ __ ] just feet and [ __ ] with
shoes on it
yeah it was [ __ ] bizarre
but abandoned skyscrapers it had badass
golf clubs though it was right out of
the crow and that's when you watch the
movie the crow crow one that's exactly
what they're talking about grapplers
will tell you he's in their comment
section it was [ __ ] bizarre
but maybe that's why i grew up so
[ __ ] weird i don't know just brazil
and detroit
all these places but grampur's hammer
said i was a canoe guide in canada at a
jewish summer camp in my college days
the camp was started in the 1930s as a
safe haven for jewish kids because
anti-semitism was so prevalent in the
cities
yeah i can imagine then no need for me
too said they had camps of asians in the
habit area of southern california where
they lived completely isolated doing
their own thing
teenagers not me would sometimes harass
them yeah that's uh that's another thing
and interestingly i didn't find out
about the american japanese internment
camps until
later they did not teach me that in
school
so i found out about it about it later
and i was just like what else are they
not telling me
but uh yeah so
yeah so we got off on a whole like
eugenics thing but so yeah so charles
lindbergh
um even though this was like before that
because like you know 1927 he did his
historic flight 1932 his kid was
kidnapped kind of like
but some of his later writings were
questionable let's call it that and even
at the time people were saying that he
was a nazi sympathizer so i'm not gonna
like take a stand on that either way i'm
just saying some of the [ __ ] that he
said they weren't taboo during that time
well yeah they weren't taboo until after
the war so they found those camps until
they were like yeah let's let's not uh
do that i mean uh the old mustache man
was man of the year [ __ ] time
magazine yeah i remember was it 30 nine
39 um
yeah before he did that [ __ ] there
wasn't much reason for uh the national
socialists to stick out people just
thought it was just another form of
european government that you could do
and boy he seemed like he was doing the
right thing mustache man
and then the war broke out you know
pearl harbor in a war and then later on
the camps and then people realized that
[ __ ]
that that happened and what's funny is
that people could not people did not
believe that that happened for a long
time i you know i can totally see that
because something like that would just
be so that's so beyond the pale yeah
that you just don't believe that like
people are capable of that but they
absolutely are and still to this day
people think that governments [ __ ]
love you and that they're trying to
protect you
no i don't think anybody thinks that
nothing well they got people to think
that
the thing governments don't work for you
they work for the rich people that own
them
they don't give a [ __ ] about you
all right
well yeah that's it
everybody knows that everybody here
knows that everybody yeah yeah yeah
grantham said detroit still produces a
serial killer or two a year they prey on
prostitutes but get caught after one or
two victims thanks to dna
honestly uh dna is probably like the
best thing to happen i feel like a lot
of serial killers that maybe would have
gone on to become horrible serial
killers get caught almost immediately
because of dna so
i'm not mad at it not at all
so okay so this is 1932 march 1st
so charles lindbergh and his wife and
their baby son who i believe was 18
months old at the time so a toddler
they were staying at their mansion
uh
in hopewell in new jersey now their
mansion was kind of like it was sort of
like this big isolated i've seen little
pictures of it like from the air and
stuff and it was this really big house
that they lived in it was kind of out in
the middle of nowhere they had like how
many i think i want to say it was 65
acres it was a big piece of property
um that now the house was mostly done
but it wasn't quite done like it was
still under construction right so the
family would only stay there on the
weekends and then the rest of the time
they stayed with i think it was charles
lindbergh's parents or his wife's
parents i can't remember but it was they
stayed with like one of their sets of
parents
now on this particular
uh this particular time though
they were staying at the house
over like it the weekend had been there
like they'd stay there over the weekend
but they stayed there extra time which
they never did
because the baby charles burke jr
was sick like he had a cold
so they didn't really want to move him i
guess or whatever so they so they stayed
in the house uh you know past the
weekend so this was actually like a
tuesday night
so the baby
has been put up to bed by the nanny or
whoever
and uh you know because they had a staff
they didn't have a huge staff that was
just kind of like i think there was
three
there was like a maid
like a grounds guy or butler or
something and then there was like a
nanny person i think that was all that
was in there
and so they put the baby to bed about 9
00 p.m or like a little bit before that
and then charles lindbergh and his wife
were just downstairs chilling apparently
now at some time
around 10 p.m
uh the kid's nurse nanny whatever uh
goes into the nursery and sees that the
nursery window is open and that the baby
is gone
so she obviously calls the parents
uh and they all rush up there
they find a
[Music]
badly spelled ransom note laying on the
windowsill
the note says let me see if i can do
this
dear sir
have fifty thousand dollars and this is
in 1932 money so that's like a [ __ ] ton
now 50 000 it's you know how in the
united states you put the dollar sign
before the
before the amount this has 50 000 and
then the dollar sign
so that'll be important
uh have fifty thousand dollars ready
r-e-d-y
uh twenty-five thousand in 20 bills 15
000 in 10 bills and 10 000 in five
dollar bills after two to four days
we'll inform you
were to deliver the money with the big m
yeah m-o-n-y m-m-o-n-y m-o-n-y yeah they
forgot the e all right
we warn you for making any ding public
or for notify the police with an s
the child is in goot care gut
indication for all letters are
signature it's supposed to be signature
but they spelled it like side like
s-i-n-g
nature and three holds that's what the
letter said
it's kind of like sloppy ass looking
handwriting good gotta say
now uh there were signs of forced entry
uh there was a broken ladder outside of
the window so obviously the person had
climbed up to the second floor window
and uh you know climbed in there with a
ladder
uh and there were some footprints on the
ground underneath the nursery window
however the nursery itself had been
completely wiped clean of fingerprints
even fingerprints that should have been
there such as the parents and the nanny
and stuff were not there so it had
obviously been wiped clean
so
i mean okay so obviously the parents
flip out and
interestingly when they start going into
this investigation uh as i said charles
lindbergh probably one of the most
famous americans in the world at the
time
and the fact that his baby son has been
taken out of his [ __ ] crib in this
house
is a massive deal so the media like
descends now interestingly charles
lindbergh had enough
money and influence
to essentially
i don't know if i want to say he took
over the investigation
but
it does seem like a lot of cops and you
know uh of the authorities and stuff had
so much respect for him that they kind
of let him
insert himself into the investigation in
a way that probably most of us
[ __ ] would not be allowed to do
but it was another era it was um and you
know like i said everybody i mean and
it's it's crazy like how much deference
they gave to him you know what i mean
uh whereas nowadays i kind of feel like
i mean yeah i mean my now it only
happened in a very small town today here
in the united states yeah i i feel like
back then i'd be like we don't give a
[ __ ] like how famous you are if you did
the [ __ ] like you're in trouble anyway
but
yeah he was pretty much allowed to run
the [ __ ] um you know from pretty much
from the outset
so as i said this was a
a media circus and
much like some of the crimes that i
talked about like in some of my books
before they really understood and this
is the 1930s this isn't like you know
19th century
but the you know the forensic science
wasn't really
you know on the vanguard or anything
like that so they didn't really have too
much problem with
press or investigators or something like
that just like coming into the crime
scene and like looking at [ __ ] and
touching [ __ ] and whatever you know what
i mean i kind of feel like that happened
in the valiska case too we're just like
hey a whole family got axe murdered like
all the neighbors are like ooh let's go
see and then they're like running
through the house and [ __ ] and nobody
stopped him so i kind of feel like that
happened a little bit uh in this uh
situation as well
so obviously uh the next day the fbi
became involved
uh and j edgar hoover uh got in on it he
was fairly young at this time
so he uh basically says all right we're
gonna give the new jersey state police
uh our you know aid and the
investigation
uh but as i said charles lindbergh was
like pretty much running the show
now one thing that charles lindbergh did
and this is not i don't know if this is
necessarily proven or something people
were talking about because lindbergh
um like a lot of kind of maybe wealthy
influential people at the time
maybe allegedly had some mob associates
so they're thinking maybe that that's
why he wanted to get involved in the
investigation because he's like man i'm
i'm going to sort this out my own way i
don't know i'm just i'm speculating but
they think maybe that's why he was uh
wanting to get involved so much because
he was like i'm gonna get some of my mob
people to go sort this [ __ ] out
so you know there was that whole issue
as well
uh because they did kind of think too
that maybe the kid had been taken
as some kind of like mob extortion type
of [ __ ] too so he maybe he was thinking
that he had
some associates that you know knew some
[ __ ] about the mob so maybe he could
like negotiate i don't know so he was
kind of doing that
now he also had this friend who was a
school principal in the bronx his name
was dr john condon
and
john condon he also decided he was going
to get involved in the investigation
and
i've seen like some newsreel footage of
him i saw this one um documentary i
think it was the pbs nova one
and one of the people on there was
saying that condon was like really a
blowhard that's the board that he used
he said he was a blowhard and so then
they showed like some uh some archival
footage of him talking about how he was
gonna like sort out this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and everything and i was like yeah i
totally get that because he he came
across as like he was like an older dude
he was retired and he came across as
very very self-important and just kind
of like this theatrical we're gonna
figure out how we're gonna do it
so it was that kind of thing
now uh it was a default setting for old
guys back then though baby it's just i'm
[ __ ] important god damn it kind of
like in korea when i was down there
respect me every old man over the age of
65 walked around with his hands behind
his back leaning forward walking around
like he was a damn gem
walk around like that inspecting [ __ ]
yeah they they really um yeah they were
really kind of selfish oh five foot one
of the [ __ ] they were all very
self important yeah they all needed
their little bubbles burst yeah i feel
like you'd be taking they told them now
they told them that once they got to a
certain age that they would run
everything yeah you're going to run
everything everyone has to listen to you
and defer to you and stuff i'm like yeah
no that's not how it works sorry that's
where kentucky kernels and crackers came
from like colonel sanders i'm gonna
certain days now i'm gonna wear a white
suit and tell y'all what to do
hold on let me cut the ribbon okay there
i'm commemorating to build another new
place there you go have you give me some
id
that's kind of like i don't know why i
don't know why but that just reminded me
of raymond's character in frogs yeah
remember that dude where they had like
the house and he was just like telling
his whole family he was like his
grown-ass children like what to do and
i'm just like
[ __ ] you're in a wheelchair i'm gonna
push you into the lake you shut up you
don't tell me what to do i'm a [ __ ]
adult [ __ ] kentucky colonel cracker
[ __ ] mentality yeah i get to tell
everybody else
i know everything no it makes sense in
afghanistan
you laugh in afghanistan they'd call him
a tribal elder
that's what they would call them it's
all it was a tribal elder
yeah yeah
camp guy says sounds like that movie
raising arizona kidnapping scene
nicholas cage i think i got the best one
i love that [ __ ] movie i really do i
think i got the best one yeah so uh all
right
so like i said he kind of took over so j
edgar hoover uh who was like i said very
young at the time so he's like offers
the fbi
you know their help in the in the issue
now the ransom note that was left at the
house like in the window that wasn't the
first one because obviously that didn't
have any you know uh
particulars for where to leave the money
or anything like that so charles
lindbergh's
keeps getting like other ransom notes uh
from the kidnapper or kidnappers which
like i said we'll get into that in a
little bit
five days after the baby was taken
uh there was another letter came to him
it was mailed from brooklyn and this one
initially they asked for fifty thousand
dollars which i'm not sure how much is
fifty thousand dollars in 1932 money i
think it was like at least half a
million
maybe more maybe six hundred thousand
i'm i'm just you know blue sky and i'm
not really sure but so this second
letter was like oh never mind now we
want seventy thousand dollars
and it also said um we don't want you to
use any intermediaries it's just gonna
be you know me and you lindbergh we're
going to sort this out
however dr condon uh the blowhard
let's call him that
i'm sure he was a nice man i don't know
he's dead now i don't know
uh i'm just saying i'm just saying like
from the footage that i saw of him i was
like oh yeah he does seem like kind of
like a blue heart but um yeah so
he says well he wants to be the
intermediary
um
so for whatever reason i'm not sure why
i'm not sure why
all of the [ __ ] that i read and like saw
about this
no one could entirely tell me why this
dr john condon person like i think he
was friends with lindbergh but why he
wanted to get so involved with the case
he was a tribal elder i'm telling you i
guess yeah like why he volunteered to be
an intermediary why he thought of
getting involved like he didn't really
have anything to do with anything what
is this again new jersey okay well in
new jersey and new york because dr
condon was from the bronx i think all
right but she's a traveler he was
kidnapped from the the baby was
kidnapped from new jersey yeah like
hopewell new jersey
so dr condon uh says well i want to be
the intermediary though
so
what they did was they gave
this problem maybe this is why so they
gave him a code name
dr condon yeah jaffzy which is
it's because john f condon it was jfc
jaffz that's what they call them so that
was his code name so they did like some
[ __ ] cloak and dagger [ __ ] where
he would publish
uh ads in the paper like classified ads
like talking to the kidnappers with the
code names and [ __ ] so maybe he was just
like he wanted he was like a spy fantasy
i'm not really sure i'm maybe i'm
imputing the guy's name i'm not really
sure i'm just saying that i was never
really clear on
why him in particular thought that he
should be involved in the case but
involved he completely
was so he takes out an ad in the paper
uh the bronx home news
and he says
after this the second letter came that
said we don't want any intermediaries he
said i'll give you guys an extra
thousand dollars
if you guys use me as a go-between okay
so like i said maybe it was like some
spy fantasy he was living out i'm not
entirely sure
now uh
interestingly the kidnappers or
kidnapper or kidnappers uh seemed okay
with this
so they were just kind of like uh sure
so they sent another letter and they
said yeah that's fine we can deal with
him
and uh you know so so condon kept
sending them messages through the
newspaper like through newspaper
classified ads i'm like oh my god it's
like desperately seeking susan because i
don't know why i thought of that but
that's what it reminded me of like all
these code names and [ __ ]
now
at this point like so the ransom letters
keep coming like back and forth it's
it's almost kind of like this wild goose
chase they were sending them on like the
family
um what they would do is they would send
one note or send like a coded message or
something and then tell them like where
to find another note
and
so all this other stuff and then finally
the family's like well how you know can
you prove to us that you have the kid
for christ's sake and you're not just
like [ __ ] around
and at this point they sent
um
a little uh the the baby who they called
charlie actually was charles lindbergh
jr but the baby had when he was taken he
had this little sleeping suit on it was
like little feety pajamas essentially
um
and so the kidnapper sent them that now
they had been washed and everything but
they sent that and they said you know
and like the nanny like identified yeah
that's what he was wearing when he was
taken
so they knew that they did actually have
the baby or had had the baby at some
point
so after that point
condon
goes to meet
uh
one of the kidnappers
in this cemetery in upper manhattan
now
he meets this guy
and
at first it's kind of like okay so he
meets this guy who they call i think the
investigators ended up calling him
cemetery john
now condon didn't get a super good look
at him as far as i could determine i
think he had kind of like a like a
handkerchief that he held over his face
um
he did say that he had kind of like a
german accent
so there was that
uh so they had some like letter
exchanges then they find the 12th ransom
note there was a lot of ransom notes
like i said
and at this point they had negotiations
[ __ ] up they had negotiated the price
the ransom down to 50 000 again which
was the original price like i said they
had they had tried to like inflate it up
to 70 000 but they talked them back down
to 50 000 so you know
so at this point they've uh figured it
out condon has met with this person
in the cemetery that he kind of saw but
not really because his face was sort of
partially concealed but he said he had a
german accent
so they get the price down to 50 000
and at this point condon is the one to
hand over the cash to the kidnapper
at which point the kidnapper says okay
the baby is on a boat called the nelly
uh right off of martha's martha's
vineyard right so
everybody's like okay fine the ransom's
been paid let's go get the baby so they
go to look for this boat and this boat
not surprisingly is not there
uh no boat no baby
now sadly
uh may the 12th which was about a month
after
uh them not finding the boat and
72 days after the baby was taken
uh they found the baby's
decomposed body damn
accidentally like it was just like a
couple hunters or some [ __ ] like that
and they'd gone like to take a leak in
the woods or something and they ended up
finding this
this kid um
sadly the baby's body was found
four and a half miles
from the hopewell mansion
where the kid had been taken from
and uh
a postmortem determined that the kid had
probably died
the same night that he was taken
so the kid had probably been dead this
whole time
that the kidnappers were damn murderer
were investigating i mean if you think
about it and i know this is going to
sound [ __ ] up if you think about it
from a practical criminal point of view
kidnapping a baby for ransom
is i mean
you're a kidnapper you're not a
babysitter yeah i know i mean i hate to
say it but most of the time i kind of
feel like if they take a baby
they're probably going to kill the baby
like immediately because they don't want
to like [ __ ] and deal with it typically
i mean to i feel like that's usually
what happens and then they'll just try
to like string the parents along until
they can actually get the money and then
they'll [ __ ] disappear which just
seemed like what they were trying to do
here you can't take care of a [ __ ]
baby that's what i'm saying criminals
yeah that's what i'm saying so i kind of
feel like
that was uh for sure what they were
trying to do here because they knew the
baby was dead the whole time i mean
the baby
was found as i said less than five miles
from the house where it'd be taken
um it looked like
the baby
had been um like killed with a blow to
the head
the quote from the time
uh the new jersey state police chief who
uh fun fact was colonel h norman
schwarzkopf the dad of the gulf war in
ormond
schwarzkopf so
yeah it was that guy so it was his dad
so he was the new jersey state police
chief at the time that this
investigation was going green sparks
says something that's right if you're
demented enough to steal a child
guarantee you can't handle taking care
of one that is absolutely correct yeah
exactly absolutely exactly so i kind of
feel like in these situations i don't
think they had any intention
of keeping the baby or giving the baby
back
i mean from a practical standpoint it
would be much better to take the baby
string the parents will just kill the
baby immediately and then string the
parents along and hopefully get the
money actually you got to think of it
this way
from a practical
point of view it would be better to
actually
take the baby and keep the baby alive
and take care of it
that way if you got caught you wouldn't
be accused of murder
that's one way of looking at it it was
just you know as an insurance policy
sure and that way you could give it back
um
but no if you're crazy enough to [ __ ]
steal a baby and hold it for ransom you
you're too crazy to take care of one
you're gonna kill it
yeah that's exactly what's going on
so yeah so the baby had been killed uh
with the blood of the head
now uh what schwarzkopf the new jersey
state police chief said at the time and
this is a quote it was as if some adult
person had held the baby tightly in his
arms and deliberately hammered the head
with the purpose of causing instant
death yeah that was the quote
now
let's see
um
he also said uh although it was possible
that the abduction and murder were spite
work it seemed more likely that the
kidnappers observing from this lookout
point that the alarm was spreading from
the lindbergh home became frightened
killed their small prisoner and fled
that was also in the newspaper reports
at the time
so
as i said like uh you know j edgar
hoover was involved in this uh the
president got involved who was franklin
roosevelt at the time
and
just [ __ ] tips poured in you got like
your hundreds and hundreds of cranks
saying i took the babies you know so
like everyone's really super helpful in
cases like these
now
one thing that was kind of not related
at the time but ended up being really
helpful in catching the person that did
it
or one of the people that did it i'll
get into that in a little bit
uh president roosevelt had taken the u.s
off the gold standard in uh the summer
of 1933.
now because of that there had been like
you know it's sort of like currency but
it was like a gold certificate that was
kind of like this you know certificate
entitles blah blah so much gold you
could like spend it like cash sort of or
you could or you could like uh cash it
in for cash is what you could do
now uh so franklin roosevelt was taking
the uh us off of that
so he had issued an executive order that
recalled all the gold coins in
circulation and the certificates worth
more than 100
now the fact that they did this
and that
i'm not really sure if it was foresight
on the part of
you know of um
lindbergh and and uh the people that
were paying the ransom money but they
paid a portion of the ransom money in
gold certificates
and obviously as you would do in any
ransom situation they took note of all
of the serial numbers on the gold
certificates okay so that's that's was a
very important thing
uh so
because that had happened um
you know all the serial numbers were
accounted for so that when they were the
gold attributes were like cashed in to
the federal government you know they
could keep track of how many of them
were still in circulation
um
so in the summer of 1934
uh because everybody in the area like in
new york and new jersey and everything
like that like all the kind of
shopkeepers had been given a little
brochure that had all of the serial
numbers of the gold certificates that
have been used to pay the ransom
so they all had that and said hey be on
the lookout for these serial numbers
so summer of 1934
um somebody
spent
16 of these gold certificates
uh in manhattan in the upper east
side and uh this is interesting because
this particular neighborhood not anymore
but back in the old days
uh this was um a lot of german
immigrants lived in this area and as i
said uh those spellings were german yeah
well and even from the beginning like
before like when they had uh experts
look at the ransom notes which had all
been written more or less by the same
person they said this is probably a
german speaker who is who has limited
english
because of the way things were
misspelled the re um you know the the
thing like some nouns were capitalized
which they do in german but they don't
do in english like [ __ ] like that it was
like little details like that so they
presumed they were looking for a german
immigrant
that didn't speak that much english and
as i said uh dr you know the the
blowhard dr blowhard um dr bluefield he
had said yeah doctor that's a full
column dr blowfall um he had said that
the guy that he was talking to quote
unquote cemetery john the guy he met up
with a couple of times he said that he
had a german accent so they were like
thinking that it was this is like a
german guy
so uh so yeah so there was like a big
german enclave in manhattan's upper east
side at the time so they thought that
was like a good sign
now interestingly
uh one of the certificates that they
found that they that was turned in by i
believe it was a gas station attendant
and they said somebody came in here and
spent this it was a ten dollar gold
certificate
and because the uh the attendant
had noticed that uh it was
weird because it's like not a lot of
people were spending gold certificates
anymore and because the uh lindbergh
kidnapping had been so
you know prevalent in the media so the
guy thought that the dude spending it
was like a little sketchy so he wrote
down his license plate number
so
the cops looked into this license plate
number and that traced them right back
to a dude named bruno richard hauptmann
who was a german immigrant
uh and he was a carpenter actually
now
so they picked this guy up pretty much
right away
now they asked him where did you get
these particular gold certificates he
said oh i got him from a dead friend of
mine which
that's almost kind of like when they
find drugs in your car they're like
they're not mine i'm holding for a
friend it's that kind of like lame
excuse so they're like okay
so they arrested him
now when they went through his
house they found
a [ __ ] ton more of the gold certificates
i believe it was 14 000
in gold certificates in his garage
and they also found dr condon's
address and phone number
penciled on a wall like in the closet
like he'd been on the phone and had
written it on there
so they asked hautman why do you have dr
condon who was the intermediary
why do you have his phone number and
[ __ ] like written on your wall that
seems a little strange
and he said oh well i guess i was just
like really into the case and i just
wrote it down because i thought i might
need a note it's like he came up with
like some really like lame excuse
everybody's like yeah we're not buying
that either
now
so
another thing too
when they uh searched his house was that
you know the latter
that they found at the scene which was
broken by the way
uh the latter was kind of like
i saw um
i saw like a a documentary that had a
thing of it i don't know if it's the
actual ladder but it was like a you know
a replica of it
and they said so it looked like somebody
with like some decent carpentry skills
had made this
and it was like
it was three layers it was like a three
layer so you could like fold it up
really small but it would go out you
know what i mean it was it was kind of
like that so he had made it out of wood
now interestingly the wood of the ladder
exactly matched some wood planks that
were in this dude's attic so it looked
like the dude had
taken some planks off of his attic floor
and fashioned them into a ladder is
essentially what it looked like they
said the [ __ ] uh you know the the
grain
matched uh they were even in the ladder
they found these uh the like nail marks
that matched up with like the joists and
his attic and all this other kind of
[ __ ] so they're like well obviously
this has got to be our guy right because
it's like that's
you know and he didn't really have a lot
of um
good he didn't really have a good alibi
as to where all this money came from
where you know why he had this dude's
phone number and address written on his
wall you know and like i said the the
latter thing and the wood in the attic
that seemed pretty definitive
so yeah so they arrest him
like i said he didn't really have a good
alibi for any of that [ __ ]
so they um
they put him on trial and now as i said
at the time
this was a massive
massive like me ever oh my god there's
like they said they had so many people
coming into the town where uh where they
were doing the [ __ ]
trial that it's just like every single
hotel was sold out it was just like
there was millions i saw like some
pictures from the time and it's just
like there's [ __ ]
thousands and thousands of people just
like cramming the sidewalks and
everything like that it was like big a
big deal now they wouldn't let
the media inside the courtroom
so what they would do
is they would
reenact the scenes like they like they
would go in and like listen to the [ __ ]
and then they would come out and reenact
the stuff
and like and reenact all the all the
dialogue if you want to call it that and
then they would like edit those and then
they would show them in the movie
theater like as newsreels so they would
do that
now there were a couple
i did see one of those online and i'm
not sure if it was a reenactment because
i think later on like i think during one
of the during bruno hautman's um you
know when the prosecution was
questioning him i think somebody like
snuck a camera in there but i'm not
really sure so it might have been a
reenactment or it might have been the
real thing i couldn't really tell
because like i said it was like really
old footage but you know and honestly i
think that this particular trial
was um
what kind of one of the trials it was
kind of like um
you know uh iconic for a lot of reasons
but i kind of feel like it was one of
those ones where
you know it it made it so that you
couldn't have cameras in the courtroom
or you could have cameras i don't even
remember what it was but it was like
some big deal about that now uh the guy
who was um
defending
hauptmann was this dude that was hired
his name was edward riley what are you
doing i don't know what she's doing holy
crap that's i don't know i just heard
noise over there i don't know what she's
up to this dude named edward riley was
uh defending him now he was actually
hired
by the new york daily mirror
uh to serve as houtman's attorney and
that was in exchange
for
uh houtman's story getting published in
their papers so they were doing on all
kind of all that kind of stuff
now as i said because they found i can't
i don't know because i've seen like
different um different um
yeah sources say some of them said
fourteen thousand dollars a gold
certificate someone said twenty thousand
dollars it was a [ __ ] ton of money of
the ransom money was in houtman's garage
um
they did a bunch of handwriting analysis
and
okay so the prosecution had eight like
handwriting analysis
is not a an exact science i'll put it
that way
uh and especially it's pretty good
though well back in the 30s though i
don't know
yeah we don't know nowadays probably
better
um back in the 30s they were actually
able the prosecution was actually able
to get eight experts i believed that
said that the spelling and handwriting
and everything like that looked like
houtmans like of in the notes now i saw
a documentary on pbs
where they did a computer
uh handwriting analysis where they said
they didn't think um that some of the
notes were written by him
but so i don't really know like i said
handwriting analysis is very we all have
certain habits we do the same things
over and over again
but it should never be the one thing
that convicts somebody because i don't
think it's it's kind of like a lie
detector in the sense that
you know yeah it could be accurate but
it might not be i think there's too much
wiggle room with your left well yeah
that's what i mean and honestly like if
i was gonna do it was like i'm not gonna
kidnap anybody for ransom obviously but
yeah you or or you do like some serial
killer or something like that where uh
one trick they'll do is they'll trace
over
printed letters yeah that's another
thing they do or you can cut words out
or cut words out yeah out of a magazine
just you know wear gloves just look at
us give them pro tips
[Laughter]
how to evade anybody that like reads
true crime like in the past that's like
old school [ __ ] that's like you could
have learned that from reading detective
stories like back in the [ __ ] early
20th century we're not telling anybody
anything they don't know everybody
watches true crime [ __ ] nowadays same
techniques over and over and over again
to evade
prosecution the best way to evade
prosecution is never get indicted
if you you don't get indicted by [ __ ]
foiling the investigative process yeah
that way they don't know the crime scene
they don't know the victim they don't
know the murder weapon they don't know
the time they don't have the suspect
they
you're not associated with it
you know
that's how it's always been done yeah
and uh
and
the world's intelligence agencies
learned it from the [ __ ] world's best
organized criminal gangs
they knew exactly how to foil well yeah
because a lot of i mean and i'm thinking
right now of the case of like uh frank
abingdale who they made catch me if you
can about who was a master forger
yeah um and he's fascinating by the way
if you ever like read that book they
made a movie about it too the movie was
okay but it had leonardo dicaprio in it
but the book is much better
um
the [ __ ] that this dude pulled was just
like crazy like i said he was a forger
and he got away with it for a really
long time like he [ __ ] flew planes he
did surgery he did all kind of crazy
[ __ ] and he would forge uh checks that
he would cash so he was like had all
this money and everything and he um
after he got caught he uh
turned and helps the fbi catch other
forgers uh using his although he was
kind of like the best of the best but
like i said that's that's what they do
i'm like hey if you know your [ __ ]
they're gonna use your information you
know to catch other people like you so
that's what they did they had some kid
his mom was rooting him on and he was
just running around they called him the
bear i think the barefoot
the barefoot thief
he would
break into people's summer homes in real
rich [ __ ] areas he was a rich kid
but he was a criminal rich kid he would
break into people's summer homes
and live in there for a while and live
in luxury and then he walked around
barefoot wherever he goes he needs
barefoot footprints and then he'd go
[ __ ] to the local airport and break
into an airplane and steal that airplane
and fly it to another airport and then
do the same things over and over again
he just lived for free
by stealing airplanes
we didn't steal the airplane well yeah
it's stealing the airplane he didn't
take it it's just he would land it and
walk away from it you know
and then make his way into the rich
summer homes of very rich people and
live in there for months and months at a
time and people [ __ ] and this [ __ ]
they were looking for him they knew
exactly who he was they couldn't catch
him for a long long time
he was on america's most wanted
his mom was rooting him on oh he's a
good kid that type of deal
[ __ ] and he he had all these advanced
skills
for
like a 22 year old dude
he could do a little bit of everything
you know [ __ ] kayaking mountain
climbing [ __ ] paris he was just a
thrill seeker yeah
but kind of like in the same lines as
these foragers that could do weird [ __ ]
you know i mean just
i don't know
yeah it just came to mind honestly he
had no problem stealing an airplane he
did not have a pilot's license
he did not know how to fly an airplane
on by the book he was just getting an
airplane to fly
like you do
that's balls
well like i said that's kind of like
what frank abignale did as well yeah um
and
as i said he he flew planes he didn't
have a pilot's license either yeah uh he
totally like put on he's you know got a
uniform somewhere and pretended he was
like a pilot and like hung out with all
the stewardesses and yeah he'd all kind
of [ __ ] chris this is back in like
the 60s i think it was the 60s i'm
confident i could fly a [ __ ]
fixed-wing aircraft i don't know about a
[ __ ]
road well i'm not confident enough to
get into it with you yeah
but do i have the balls to get into an
airplane [ __ ] if it's not a life or
death situation and [ __ ] fly and land
it
man it had to be a life or death see
that's what i mean it's like i you know
if i had to i could probably like take
off and fly it blending it that's a
whole other issue
i know the basics i'm sure i can get the
feel for it
you know i know i know the very basics
just why would i put myself at that kind
of risk
but you got to look at it this way the
dangerous landing
that's what i just think when you're
landing you're under 100 miles an hour
and you're already on the ground anyway
so it's no worse than a motorcycle wreck
that's true okay
so i can see it that way
but it would be nerve-wracking to be in
the sky
at [ __ ] 40 000 feet flying that
[ __ ]
that in the clouds
not really knowing what you're doing
yeah no thanks yeah i mean
like what happens if you get into a
stall
that's what i mean i'm sure i could get
out see that's what that's why pilots
training is important because i kind of
feel like one of the things they train
you for like probably flying the [ __ ] is
easy when everything's going good it's
the emergency it's when yeah it's like
okay well what happens if this happens
what contingency plans yeah uh that's
one thing that you can't really learn on
the fly because you're yeah you get into
a flat spin
in a cessna and you can't power out of
it how do you get out of that [ __ ]
i mean usually this is to put nose down
try to get as much [ __ ] speedies but
will you nose down in a flat spin
probably not i don't know i don't know
i'd have to do some time on a simulator
and read up on [ __ ]
but unprepared i couldn't just jump into
a [ __ ] single seat
propeller plane and go yeah i'm gonna
fly this [ __ ] and land and be totally
confident i'd be [ __ ] my pants
well see the thing about it is that
if somebody did do that you only hear
about the ones that succeed probably
like the 50 other people that tried to
do it and didn't succeed are dead so you
don't hear about it
i have a feeling that a kid was a
[ __ ] psychopath
he just didn't have any damn
stress because he just didn't he didn't
care he didn't
because he just didn't care that's what
i mean like in some ways yeah that's
kind of cool not to have any fear of
anything but they don't have any they
don't have any feelings about anything
yeah that's why they can do [ __ ] like
that because they don't care about
anything they don't have any emotions
about anything yeah sheila ann says the
latter's rungs were spaced far apart
could definitely drop a baby coming down
it's dark i honestly kind of thought
that too because the ladder that they
found which was left at the scene was
kind of broken
so there were um some theories uh
swirling
that the kidnapper or kidnappers
actually didn't intend to kill the baby
or didn't intend to kill the baby right
away but that in the process of bringing
the baby down from the window uh that
the latter broke and they dropped the
baby and so they were like well [ __ ]
yeah i do think although i've seen some
other um
i've seen like some kind of like modern
pathologists and stuff like look at the
skull
and they're like to me they're like you
know this one injury on one side of the
skull they're like yeah that could have
been caused by a fall but there was also
an injury on the other side of the skull
which looked like it was caused more
like uh on purpose maybe they injured
the baby and then finished it off so
maybe i'm not really sure but yeah that
is a possibility that they dropped the
baby off the ladder because the ladder
was actually kind of broken
uh and it was you know so if you dropped
him from like two story so there is that
um but that is one thing that is up so i
don't you know i don't know if that
necessarily
i mean i guess that could have happened
but as i said i kind of feel like they
didn't really have any intention of
keeping the baby i think they were
intending probably to kill the baby at
some point maybe they maybe they just
dropped him and they were like well we
were gonna kill him anyway so it seemed
like we just we just killed him earlier
than we thought
because like i when they found the baby
they said well the decomposition points
to him being killed probably the night
he was taken
and the fact that he was less than five
miles from the house
would seem to back up that assertion
um
because if he hadn't died
the night of the abduction
then why would he only be like less than
five miles away from the house because
the kidnappers if it was who they said
it was
you know lived in [ __ ] new york
and you know the
hopewell house the lindbergh's house in
new jersey
was a big estate it had like a bunch
like a huge like i said i saw a picture
of it from the air like back then and it
was like a massive like 60 something
acres so there was just like land all
around it so i don't think anybody would
have come back there later like could
kill the baby and then come back there
to bury it so i kind of feel like he
probably did die whether it was
accidental or a purpose i'm not entirely
sure but yeah they absolutely could have
like dropped them from the ladder so i
don't so i don't really know
so uh as i mentioned uh yeah so at the
trial they brought forth all the stuff
about the
ladder being made of the same um planks
as in the attic
and remember this is the quote that i
was trying to remember
uh remember when i said they asked him
like why do you have
dr condon's address
written on your wall in pencil and his
phone number and this is what bruno
hauptman said
he said
i must have read it in the paper about
the story i was he was german so his
english was not great i was a little bit
interested and keep a little bit record
of it and maybe i was just on the closet
and was reading the paper and put it
down the address
i can't give you any explanation about
the telephone number he's lying and this
well this is on the stand yeah so the
fact that he couldn't come up with even
like a plausible setting story
i mean come on
now some other circumstantial evidence
that was uh you know brought up by the
prosecution was also they're like dude
this this guy was like a carpenter he
didn't have a [ __ ] ton of money
uh however
not too long after the kidnapping
he had bought a 400
radio which
four hundred dollars in the 1930s um i
looked it up and that's like almost
eight thousand dollars
eight thousand dollars for a radio
what kind of what the [ __ ] did this
radio like wipe your ass and was it like
gold-plated and had [ __ ]
can contact mars and [ __ ] holy crap
[ __ ] ate that i can't imagine what a
radio that would would do that would
make it worth 8 000
you know what i'm saying even back then
i mean i know it was a bigger deal and
everything but holy [ __ ] but yeah so he
had uh bought this really expensive
radio
and
um his wife had gone on a trip to
germany
and
they just thought it was fishy because
they're like yeah he couldn't he
wouldn't really be able to afford that
like on his salary unless he had all
this extra money
now interestingly condon
later identified
hauptmann it's interesting because his
name is bruno richard hautman but from
everything that i could determine even
though bruno was his first name
um he usually went by his middle name so
he
he usually was called richard hauptman
but everybody just calls him bruno
hammond
so
dr condon said yeah this was the guy
that
that i met up with in the cemetery
that i you know gave the note that i
gave the money to
although i will note
that dr condon said that at the trial
but when they questioned him at first
that's not what he said and to be honest
the sketch that they did of the guy that
he saw
you know what it might be bruno
hauptmann but some other [ __ ] that came
out later makes me think that it might
be another dude uh but i'm not entirely
sure there's there's the possibility it
could just be bruno but it's interesting
that
dr condon
um when they first arrested bruno
hauptmann and they asked dr conan is
this the guy you saw he'd he wouldn't
identify him he's like i'm not really
sure but then at the trial he came
forward and he's like yeah that's
totally him you know what i'm saying so
i don't know so there's a little bit
fishy there too
um so there was that and they had like a
bunch of other witnesses uh come forward
like people that had been working at the
stores where the other gold certificates
were spent and said yeah that's the same
guy blah blah blah they also said that
he had been
out of work
on the day that the ransom was paid so
there was that and then two days later
he had quit his job
uh and that he had continued to live a
comfortable lifestyle even though he
didn't get another job so there was that
whole thing too you missed the part
about the eight thousand dollar radio
an 8 000 radio well
back in the 30s
they said that one of the things was
that well he must have come into some
money because he bought a radio that in
19 in the 1930s cost 400
which in today's money is almost 8 000
and i said what the [ __ ] could a radio
do that would make it worth 8 000
what i can't think of a single thing
some really good speakers on it i can't
think of a single thing honestly i can't
think of a single thing i can't think of
a single electronic thing nowadays that
i would pay eight thousand dollars think
of the five thousand dollar uh vcrs
that we used to see when we were kids
which why it's like it could have been
that much better
than
i mean well it was very early 80s
remember and the [ __ ] vcr was a
thousand to begin with and some of the
most [ __ ] were 5 000
because they could they were very
expensive back in the old days well i
think the 5 dollar ones could copy a
[ __ ] v8 vcr tape but then like a few
years later we got one
and it was like 100 or 200 yeah right
but some people had to have that [ __ ]
first and it was made out of wood meant
a wood grain looking [ __ ] yeah it
wasn't even real wood i don't know
it was just kind of like that [ __ ]
cheap ass
it looks like you press a button
[Music]
like that
oh i feel like i'm on the [ __ ]
enterprise god damn
so cool
i just honestly i can't think of a
single thing
electronic thing that's cool enough that
i would spend eight that even if i had
eight thousand dollars i can't think of
a single thing
man i don't even i don't even like to
spend eight thousand dollars on a
[ __ ] car when i was a little kid in
[ __ ] very late 70s early 80s i
remember people that had [ __ ]
laserdisc
they were like a [ __ ] album
yeah remember those they were [ __ ]
[ __ ] they were [ __ ] [ __ ] expensive
too super expensive i know i told you i
worked and spent like [ __ ] 100 i
worked at a record store in 1993 and
they sold some in there although
honestly the whole time i worked there i
never saw a single person buy one they
were too expensive we only had two racks
of them we did have them available but
yeah thank you jeffy art i like your
little like dance look at the little
dancing fox woo he's farting
out [ __ ] funny
hearts he's a hard farter thank you
that's what he is
yeah maria says the radio had a cultural
and social significance at that time
that we have a hard time understanding
now yeah i get that and they you know
they didn't have tv and everything like
that but
still
man a radio only really does one thing
you just like listen to programs on it
back in the old days you'd listen to
like the shadow or whatever was on in
the 1930s that might have been a little
bit after that i can't remember because
my grandpa used to listen to that when
he was younger the shadow knows he
always used to say so um you know and i
was when i was a kid i was like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about grandpa but
you know i learned later but so i i
don't know i just can't think of
anything that would necessitate
400 in in those days money
on a radio
i don't know it must have been a really
awesome radio that's all i'm saying it
had naked ladies and it made bacon and i
don't know what the [ __ ] it did but yeah
eight thousand dollars so yeah so he had
spent all this money on expensive [ __ ]
like cities but sent his wife to germany
and all this other stuff even though he
didn't really seem to have
a job or a job that would you know give
him enough money to be doing that kind
of [ __ ]
so um
so then so the prosecution's just kind
of like okay well we rest our case then
the defense comes up now uh
the defense's whole case and bruno
hautman pleaded not guilty and um you
know he pretty much
uh maintained his innocence until the
very end
um
yeah he would not go back on it
the whole defense was that the money
wasn't his which like i said
okay
he said that he had a friend named
isidor fish
uh who had
left the money in his garage
and i'm guessing i think he said that
he's like well i didn't really know what
it was from or what you know what the
deal with it was but he was just keeping
it there like in my garage
coincidentally conveniently isidore fish
apparently had gone back to germany in
late 1933
and had died there i believe of
tuberculosis so he wasn't there to like
call for the defense he was dead
so he so haltman says i didn't even
really know like i was just out there in
the garage and i found this box
that fish had left there and there was
like all this money in it which was
forty thousand dollars so after fish
died i was like [ __ ] it and just started
spending it
possible sure
plausible
not really
uh and even his own wife said you know
this box that he says was in this garage
she's like i used to hang my apron up
there all the time i didn't see any
[ __ ] box but i didn't notice it like
all these years later
uh so so there was that
and basically it's kind of like um
they had some other witnesses that came
forward like the prosecution had some
witnesses that said look this is a door
fish guy he did exist he wasn't just
like made up
but
it's like look he couldn't have
done what he did like he was somewhere
else at the time
and
he actually ended up dying of
tuberculosis
and his landlady said that he was so
broke that he couldn't like even afford
his tuberculosis treatments or his rent
or anything so it seemed unlikely that
he
had had all this money somehow
so nobody really bought that story
um now so the defense attorney that was
pretty much the only defense they had
they didn't really have any defense
about the you know the wood matching
from the attic and the latter and all
that and like i said his excuse for
you know having the dude's phone number
and address written on his wall was a
little lame
so
they didn't really have much they were
just kind of like well yeah but all the
you know all of the um evidence is just
it's circumstantial they didn't nobody
saw him at the scene they never found
his fingerprints actually they didn't
find anybody's fingerprints on the scene
because it had all been wiped down
um and they pointed out like some
inconsistencies like some of the
witnesses so like i said dr condon who
said
who didn't identify houtman at first
like when he was first arrested he's
like i'm not sure if that's him but then
i definitively id him at the trial so
they kind of pointed that contradiction
out as well it's like oh so he wasn't
even sure but now he's sure blah blah
um so the one scene that i saw and like
i said i'm not sure if this is real or
if it was a reenactment but there was
one point where the prosecutor and bruno
hauptman was like on the stand and they
got into this big [ __ ] like screaming
match and it was just like it's really
interesting to watch i'm not sure if
it's actors like i said if it was a
reenactment i think it was the real
thing because i think somebody like
snuck a [ __ ] in there but
it was like it was pretty good like they
released it to just the media and
everybody saw it because like i said
they were they were showing like the
dailies i guess if you call them that
from the trial they were showing them in
movie theaters like as newsreels like
before movies and stuff
so um yeah so as i said this is kind of
like uh
this was the thing remember when i said
before that this is one of those kind of
like iconic trials that made so after
this trial they banned cameras from
inside courtrooms for a long time that's
i don't think it's banned anymore but uh
it was for a long time
so
at this point bruno houtman
he absolutely uh maintained his
innocence as i said he would not confess
and a hearst newspaper which you know
you guys know about those been to his
house
what william randolph hearst yeah his
house
i was a little kid yeah out in
california my mom took me
yeah that's kind of a famous first
castle
yeah that's kind of it looks like a damn
greek [ __ ]
gardens outside and
it's like something out of the movies
yeah you can go
yeah i think a lot of people have been
there it's like yeah i've seen pictures
of it yeah
but um yeah so
one of the hearst newspapers there were
several
but they gave him they said that they
would give him and his family like a
[ __ ] ton of money if he would just
confess to the crime
but bruno hauptman would not
so
i think the fact that he wouldn't
confess even when
you know the newspaper guy said we'll
give you all this money like even if you
know you get go to jail or whatever like
your family at least will have it
because he had a wife and a kid
um i think that was one of the main
things that maybe
got people thinking later that maybe he
was innocent
but i'll get into that in a second
so
he offered him all this money but he
wouldn't plead guilty
uh he also got a last-minute offer to
commute his sentence from the death
penalty to life without portal because
he did get the death penalty
um so they said well you can do that
i don't i'm not entirely sure what all
the parameters were like i don't know
why exactly they made that offer but
they said you can commute it to life
sentence and he uh again
refused um they said that that was
contingent upon him confessing to the
crime and he absolutely would not
so he would rather die
than confess to the [ __ ] i don't know if
it was because
he didn't want his
family um to live with the shame
i'm not really sure what it was but he
was actually willing to
get killed
if he indeed was innocent which i'm
gonna say right now i don't think he was
but
if he was he was absolutely like not
gonna confess like to and he was willing
to die for it so
uh the trial lasted six weeks he got
sentenced to death and uh he he got two
appeals like you normally would and he
was electrocuted in april of 1936.
now because he would not confess
uh and because of some other [ __ ]
you know some other contradictions that
were brought up at the trial
pretty much right after he was executed
people started thinking maybe
um there was some other [ __ ] going on in
this case
now there's three schools of thought on
this uh one school of thought saying
that bruno hautman was completely
innocent and was essentially just
railroaded because this was a high
profile case uh so some people have even
gone these are kind of like the more
crazy conspiracy theories where they're
like every like all of the [ __ ] was like
engineered or he was you know or they
basically like railroaded him into it
because they wanted to solve it because
it was so high profile
so some people are saying he was
completely innocent he was he was just
like a patsy
uh then there are some that said he
worked alone which is basically what the
fbi said that's what the court said
because they were they executed him then
there's like the middle ground
where
he was guilty but he had uh
associates that were never apprehended
and that's pretty much where i'm falling
i think
that
he did it but i don't think he worked
alone i just don't think that they
caught the other people that's all
and it's not that crazy because
we'll get in a second
so
i so like i said i don't think he's
completely innocent there are some that
do his wife maintained she died she
lived a long time she died in 1994
and um
she maintained his innocence so that she
even tried to sue the state of new
jersey like for wrongful execution and
all this other kind of stuff and she
didn't win but you know what i mean
she basically you know said that he
didn't do it she she lived a long time
though she died when she was 95 years
old
now
so the thing about this i okay
i think he had at least one other
confederate maybe two
because one thing that was kind of
interesting there were some
um
they found some footprints at the scene
right
and
it appeared that the footprints that
were kind of like going from the ladder
like out of the you know of the yard or
whatever
it appeared that there were two sets of
footprints and indeed it would be much
easier if you were climbing up a ladder
and like taking a baby out of a nursery
and blah blah
it would be easier to like hand them off
to another person
rather than like working [ __ ] by
yourself but they did say
initially in the initial police reports
as far as i'm aware that there were two
sets of footprints but at the trial
later
uh i think the cops just said there was
one set or didn't mention it okay so
there was that
um and like i said i'm not saying that
bruno hatman didn't do it i think he was
there
but i think that he had uh help i think
there was a a little i don't know if i'd
call it a gang because i don't think it
was that many people but i think it was
like two or three people
now interestingly too
as i mentioned near the beginning of the
show
normally
the lindbergh family would not be at the
hopewell house
on a tuesday evening
because the house was not finished uh it
was still under construction so they
only stayed there on weekends now the
only reason they were there on this
particular night was because the baby
had been sick
nobody knew this except for the family
members and perhaps some members of the
household staff
leading a lot of investigators to
believe
that
at least
one of the somebody involved in this
maybe
it was an inside job
in the sense that somebody might have
given information to someone else
whether it was bruno hautman whether it
was one of the alleged confederates
um there might have been somebody that
was working in the household
that
knew that the family was going to be
there because the world at large did not
know that normally they were only there
on weekends and they were never there on
tuesday nights also the person that
kidnapped the baby knew exactly where
the nursery was
which again leads me to believe that
they had some information from inside
the house possibly from one of the
staff
uh being the nurse the nanny the butler
whoever
now at the time of the investigation
even at the time of the investigation in
the 1930s uh the detectives thought that
too because they thought it was very
strange that the baby had been kidnapped
on a night when the family would
normally not be there
so one of the people they were looking
at
was this woman named violet sharp now
she was actually the maid of
lindbergh's was it lindbergh's parents
it was the house they normally stayed at
in uh englewood
it was either lindbergh's parents or his
wife's parents i can't remember now but
they had a maid named violet sharp
and
she was a suspect at the time not for
actually kidnapping the kid but for
giving whoever kidnapped the kid
information that the where the nursery
was and blah blah blah
interestingly they questioned her
and she said some weird [ __ ] like she
kind of said some contradictory kind of
stuff like they couldn't really get a
straight story out of her
so they were kind of interested and they
thought maybe she was involved so they
set up another interview with her
the day before this other interview
she committed suicide
so
guilty very interesting
so as i said she's just been in on it i
definitely think that they had help
inside the house
she's been in on it but it didn't go
according to plan
that's kind of what i'm leaning she felt
guilty so she killed herself
i mean that's kind of where i'm leaning
i think that
at least somebody in the house had to
have informed like the kid maybe the
dropping of the baby thing might there
might be something to that yeah
maybe she didn't want the baby to be
killed
but she just wanted to get some [ __ ]
money some money right which they must
have dropped the baby and then they're
like well [ __ ] no let's go to plan b
maybe they injured the baby seriously
and then killed the baby yeah
and then she's like oh [ __ ] then she
killed herself once she was questioned
yeah because she's like oh they're on to
me or whatever no i'll never get away
with it i mean yeah i mean that does
seem like pretty cause it doesn't i mean
the the timing of her
suicide is suspicious and they did say
that when they interviewed her at first
they said that she
said some weird [ __ ] i'd you know i
haven't read the transcript or anything
but they said she made some
contradictory statements they couldn't
get really a straight story out of her
it's evidence
that's evidence yeah evidence that she
felt responsible
yeah okay so i kind of feel like whether
it was just bruno hauptman whether it
was more than one person i definitely
think there was somebody that was
working in the household that
told them
what was going on where the baby's room
was and [ __ ] like that like yeah oh like
call maybe she called them up and said
hey they you know normally they would
have left by now but they're here and
this is where the window is and [ __ ]
like that i kind of feel like there was
that
so uh so yeah so
some other theories about it and i'll
kind of get into because i think
somebody brought it up like uh earlier
on but i'll get into that in a little
minute too as far as like inside job
stuff goes
so there's this guy and he's a scottish
uh journalist and he's kind of looked
into this case for a long time his name
is uh ludovic kennedy
and he honestly thought
he thought that uh that haltman was
completely innocent he thought that a
lot of the um
the stuff about like the latter that had
been made from the attic boards and
stuff like that was
planted or manufactured which like i
said not impossible but
the more the bigger the conspiracy gets
like the more intricate the less
believable it is because it's just too
many moving parts so i don't know if i
necessarily buy that i think there was
too much evidence saying that bruno
hauptman was involved
but there are some authors out there
that do think that he was completely
railroaded that a lot of the evidence
was
you know planted on him or manufactured
or whatever
they did actually
there was a book he wrote that came out
in the 80s called the airman and the
carpenter
and um
this movie was actually made into a
movie on hbo in 1996 called the crime of
the century that had stephen ray and
isabella rossolini in it which i think
somebody mentioned uh earlier i don't
think i've seen it actually although it
sounds kind of familiar maybe i have
seen it it was a long time ago i'll make
us some food when this is over
you think about that crab salad
oh yeah that sounds good actually about
that crab didn't you yeah no i didn't
forget about it and then i got a bunch i
got so much a coleslaw mix i need to we
need to use up i'll make that into a
salad with some crab salad on it okay
all right
um all right so let's get into a little
bit what uh
what one of the uh people in the chat
was talking about earlier
there are some schools of thought as far
as inside job goes
that charles lindbergh himself
was behind this but what not
well maybe not necessarily whether he
wanted the kid to die or not
but
charles lindbergh
uh as i mentioned earlier was you know
kind of beloved by america and stuff but
he seemed like he was maybe not the
nicest dude um according to a couple of
documentaries i saw and some stuff that
i read they said that he was um
a prankster and not a prankster like oh
boy like jolly fun but a lot of kind of
like he would do like really cruel [ __ ]
and they said in particular
allegedly
he had pulled a prank before on his wife
i hesitate to call it a prank this
because this is not funny
but he essentially took the baby
and hid the baby
and then told her that the baby had been
kidnapped
uh and this was i believe it was a few
months before the actual kidnapping
uh because i guess he thought it was
funny i don't know
but he was kind of pulling [ __ ] like
that all the time
which
again suspicious now what a lot of
people in like one why i brought up the
whole like eugenics thing and everything
like that and what some people have
speculated is that maybe
he didn't really want the kid around i'm
not saying he wanted the kid dead but
i'm saying he maybe he didn't want the
kid around maybe he wanted to like
quietly put the kid in an institution
and he thought like
having him kidnapped would be the best
way to do that
because
um the kid
supposedly
had some
uh physical
i don't want to say let's say
abnormalities
how severe they were is
up for debate
um some people said oh well he couldn't
even like he was 18 months you know so
he was almost two
and it's like that he couldn't really
stand up uh on his own and his toes like
overlapped each other
um his doctor at the time the medical
reports at the time said that he was
quote unquote rickety meaning he might
have had rickets
but if he did it was probably like a
mild case
um he didn't have because if you've seen
some people that have like really severe
rickets where they're like their legs
are just like out like that like i've
seen some pictures of people with it and
um and where they couldn't like really
walk at all
uh probably the baby didn't have it that
bad if he did have it did seem like he
might have had mild rickets
but um and also he had another thing
where you know his fontanelle had not uh
it's the the soft spot on the baby's
head you know where the skull hasn't
grown over like when they're born um it
hadn't healed completely which it
normally would have by the time he was
that age
so some people have speculated that
because lindbergh was all into eugenics
and he thought that he was part of the
master race
and the fact that this kid that he had
was not
perfect
was yeah was maybe causing him just like
well maybe i'm not you know maybe i'm
not as genetically superior as i thought
i was
so i'm an engineer like i said i'm not
saying that he necessarily had the kid
killed or anything but some people have
speculated that oh he staged a
kidnapping and then he was going to have
the kid put an institution somewhere and
you know have him kind of disappear like
i said it's far fish it's far-fetched
far-fetched um
i will say that it is a far-fetched uh
proposition but some people have put
that out there i will say one thing
though
later on like after the whole debacle
with the kidnapping and you know them
finding the baby dead and this whole
thing
uh him and his wife i don't remember how
long it was afterward it might have been
like after the hautman trial was over
but they moved to europe i don't know if
it was germany or not but like i said he
was kind of like i don't know if i want
to say cozying up to the nazis but he
was kind of like hanging with them
and another thing
that uh that lindbergh did which
actually didn't come out until much
later like probably like the 60s because
everyone just thought he was like i said
america's sweetheart or whatever the
male equivalent of that is
when he was in germany he allegedly
supposedly had another
persona like he had a fake name
and he went around
uh
because of his superior genes he went
around impregnating
a bunch of other women
so he had
seven or eight other kids because he
wanted to spread his superior genes
around that's that has something in the
spirit of genes yeah well that's that's
what his thinking was how do you know
that
that's apparently i don't know i've
heard that in a lot of places not just
[ __ ] it's just it's just just [ __ ]
hunger it might be yeah but like i said
because well because of it
well because of his writings like the
the [ __ ] that he wrote about race and
eugenics and stuff uh people are like
yeah we're pretty sure that he thought
that his genes were so awesome that he
needed to like spread them it's not far
and wide it's not just anglo-saxon folks
[ __ ] jeffrey epstein [ __ ] thought
the same thing he had superior genes he
had a whole foundation to impregnate all
these little foreign all these florida
girls
now i don't know what they did with the
babies
one story is is that they [ __ ]
blended them up and [ __ ] reinjected
them back into his veins as some kind of
anti-age
[ __ ] technology now that again sounds
very far-fetched dna some kind of dna
treatment clones of yourself
one theory is that he's making clones of
himself
and having girls carry them to term
and then the clones born and you use the
[ __ ] parts
i don't know like parts of the clonus or
like the clone of that movie
horror technology man [ __ ] biotech is
[ __ ]
probably
sorry i was just i was thinking i was
just thinking of that one episode of
mystery science theater where serbo made
a bunch of clones of himself and crow
was like like you're so cool we need
more of you yeah
they got [ __ ] mega maniacs out there
to [ __ ] think that well that's why it
makes me laugh because i'm like i'm sure
that's what people are thinking and
what's funny is that a lot of these
[ __ ] [ __ ] that have all this money
or basic [ __ ] when you get down to it
there's nothing really special about
them
and when you give an average
[ __ ] that much money and power
he acts he acts a [ __ ] fool
acts a [ __ ] well most people will act
a [ __ ] fool if they know that they
can get away with anything
you know
they don't they don't [ __ ] carry
clones of me i mean you know they don't
have there aren't any consequences
there's no consequences and if you take
consequences away then people will do
all kind of crazy [ __ ] yeah you know
so you know that's
actions have consequences for peons like
us but not for them not for people with
all the money yeah
so so yeah so i i so i'm just saying
that i saw like um on the end of a
documentary they said like back in the
i want to say it was like maybe the 90s
or the early 2000s or the mid-2000s
where a bunch of lindbergh's um you know
they had done dna tests a bunch of
lindbergh's like grown children came
forward and uh they were like yeah he
was going all over [ __ ] europe like
impregnating women left and right with
his superior genes so here's so here's
all the like grown children so they were
talking about that but like i said that
didn't come out until a lot later
uh you know so
that kind of like fueled the whole
maybe he had the baby taken away by
kidnappers
because the baby was
genetically inferior because maybe he
had brickets or maybe he had some other
problems but like i said but from at
least from the medical [ __ ] that i
looked at from the time
um they said yeah maybe the baby had
briquettes but it was not
it was like smiled
um but he didn't really seem to have
anything else wrong with wrong with him
you know what i mean he was a cute ass
baby if you like look at a picture of
him which is so it's kind of sad i don't
think there's something wrong with the
baby i don't think there's anything
wrong with the baby either like i said
like i said maybe mild rickets but
that's his just they said
his toes were overlapped like all his
toes were overlapped that's all they
said he was a lot of [ __ ] ugly
ass toes i was born with ugly ass toes
tom was born with ugly ass yeah well
you've told that story haven't you feet
are [ __ ] ugly they're not
well some people have [ __ ] cute ass
little hamster feet and [ __ ]
sometimes some girl is [ __ ] blessed
with [ __ ] cute cute-ass
[ __ ] house little mouse feet but by
the time you're in your 40s and 50s this
[ __ ] is some busted ass luckily that
look ugly ass looking [ __ ] toes i
don't think but larson toes my feet
don't look that bad no yours aren't that
bad look at brie larson's [ __ ] i have
flat feet but that's about it yeah
here's a flat [ __ ] have you ever seen
brie larson's toe why would i have seen
brie larson's that [ __ ] watch his dad
walks down the red carpet with open-toed
shoes and then why would i be looking at
her toes i wouldn't look because she
talks so much [ __ ] and then people
[ __ ] started posting pictures [ __ ]
on our toes and see like you know look
at your okay
you don't understand it
no because because i have better things
to do
[ __ ] busted ass looking [ __ ] toes
i saw them
i'm just saying they're like claws i
have better things to look at people's
yeah they're like claws
you know i mean feet in general i mean
unless you have a foot fetish feet in
general are not an attractive part of
the human body
so age out quickly you know what i mean
like sometimes sometimes some girl might
have some cute feet
but like i said they don't last because
you're putting those feet in [ __ ]
shoes and walking around on them your
whole life and they [ __ ] get all
gnarly and [ __ ] see this is why i only
put shoes on when i go outside yeah well
i'm in the house i'm barefoot
i don't i don't like watching i don't
like wearing shoes yeah shoes aren't
good for your feet walk around barefoot
that's how we evolved but um not outside
but you know jenny will tell you
anything
no i won't but i can walk around
barefoot outside on the ground that's
not what i just that's not what i just
said what did i just say okay what did i
just say i said to egypt i said not
outside i lived quote unquote
i'm hanging out with them [ __ ] we're
sitting there [ __ ] cooking food over
the fire and their [ __ ] feet look
like shoes
their feet look like leather shoes
[ __ ] they were flat
that much [ __ ] callous on the bottom
of them they could run across the sand
[ __ ] all that damn
sad hot as [ __ ] 150 degree [ __ ] sand
and they just [ __ ] stand there and
the [ __ ] bacon say it well because
they got a callus on the bottom of their
shoe thicker than the [ __ ] soul of a
damn leather shoe
all right
the women the same way
oracle says ballet dancers have scary
looking toes yes they do yes they do
well that's because
they're on those [ __ ] toe shoes all
the time which i wore when i was a
little kid but i didn't you know if you
did years and years of that yeah your
toes are gonna be all [ __ ] up actually
some ballet dancers like their toenails
like fall out in general you want in
general you want to avoid
feet
you just
[Laughter]
hard to avoid feet you kind of have to
walk on them i got a shoe fetish all
right he's got a shoe fetish everybody
hates feet not a foot like a shoe fitted
i love shoes
and
it's not so bad where i just need the
shoe i got to have the woman and the
shoe it's [ __ ] bonus you know yeah
not just the shoe just the [ __ ] yeah
some dudes have like [ __ ] the [ __ ]
i'm just gonna sleep with this shoe
so bad they don't even need the woman
okay i'm not that bad
oh my god
yeah oracle says yeah trust us folks
don't google images of ballet dancers
feet yeah yeah don't uh tammy says i
never have shoes on inside either
honestly to me
i don't know i've never been a kind of
person and like i know like people are
kind of one way or the other about it
because i was just reading an article
about this the other day
um
oh you know what it was i was watching a
video about like british people react to
like weird [ __ ] in america
and they have a perception over there
that all americans wear shoes inside the
house because that's what they've seen
on tv and in movies and i said well on
tv and in movies they probably just have
like the actors have the shoes on
because you know they don't want to have
to like take them on and off like you
know when they're on the set yeah yeah
well it looks better too but yeah and it
looks better so um but i said i think
it's about 50 50. some people uh you
know they get up they get dressed they
put shoes on i wear shoes all day yeah
he wears shoes all day um i don't
because to me that's it's dirty
um because i wash my feet two or three
times a day i never wash the bottom of
shoes
so i just kind of feel like you know
bare feet that have been washed are
cleaner than shoes that don't get washed
so
i don't know so honestly i just grew up
as soon as now i would never go to
somebody's house who i didn't know all
that well and take my [ __ ] shoes off
okay now if somebody told me hey we
don't wear shoes in the house i'd be
like okay fine and i would take my shoes
off because i know people have that but
i'm not gonna take my shoes off in
someone else's house unless they tell me
i can or unless it's like family or like
really close friends or something but
when i'm in my own house i never wear
shoes i only wear shoes if i go outside
see i clean floors
i got carpet shampooers and vacuumers
and [ __ ] like that so
i don't worry about it and i don't i
don't get on the floor that much
if i get on the floor i got little rugs
i get on i got [ __ ] arabic prayer
rugs i get down work on [ __ ]
i i actually
i actually don't like to sit in chairs
i'd actually like to either lay in beds
or sit on floors but i'm mostly standing
we're sitting on like that little damn
box
thing
interestingly i don't like chairs that
much well i sit on this chair but i like
this chair because it's wide so i can
sit cross-legged yeah which is like i'm
sitting on the floor because i can't sit
in a chair like a normal person because
my legs are short
and so after a while like my feet touch
the floor but it's still not super
comfortable yeah my first instinct when
i get in a chair
is
sit cross-legged in the chair so i can't
sit in chairs that are too narrow for me
to do in general i don't like your
average american house
the average american house is filled
with a bunch of junk
there's too much furniture in it from my
point of view
uh there's a bunch of little [ __ ]
knickknacks and fufu goes back to my
grandmother's era and [ __ ]
people will have too much goddamn stuff
in a [ __ ] house
they get a little bitty [ __ ] house
they're poor and then the next thing you
do is they jam pack that [ __ ]
full of cheap furniture and [ __ ] like
collectors plates and [ __ ] little
statues that's like a whole person thing
all that [ __ ] needs to be thrown out
less is less is better
i like simple clean stuff
you know
i just i just don't understand it
every little [ __ ] nook and cranny has
got to have some kind of [ __ ]
piece of goddamn furniture in it that
you don't use
it's just stupid
zach says unless i have to go somewhere
real important i usually don't wear
underwear hashtag free the testicle man
he's coming onto my channel trying to
track men okay
[ __ ] nobody cares you run around
command though everybody runs around
commando does too
well it depends on what i'm doing but
yeah yeah it depends on what i'm wait if
i'm wearing something that's gonna like
have vpl then i won't right but if it's
a skirt or something like that then yeah
i'm gonna put like some [ __ ] little
put some little booty shorts on
underneath that [ __ ] oracle says i wear
slippers inside the house as a rule and
yeah a lot of people have that like
particularly like i think asian
households asian americans uh you know
they think it's dirty like to wear
houses like warehouses wear shoes inside
the house so they'll usually have like
house slippers
you know so you take your shoes off as
soon as you come in and you put the
slippers on and watch a lot of that has
to do with asia if you live in korea
those [ __ ] spit on the [ __ ]
ground all the time outside throats
chewing gum and [ __ ] and they're in a
very heavily
heavily highly populated areas so
they're constantly in a metropolitan
area so yeah you're walking across yeah
but around here it's like people walk
their dogs and there's dog poopy and
stuff like that like you know
so i'm not like i never stepped in any
dog [ __ ] around here i although i saw
some when we were walking yesterday i
walk on pavement
there were some on the pavement i didn't
see it i saw it oh so you didn't see it
so it didn't exist
if it didn't happen to him it didn't
happen nope
i even told you no i said oh look dog
[ __ ] on a lawn i don't here's the thing
he does not listen [ __ ] get
sensitive i when i was in the army i
would [ __ ] get up in a damn pile of
leaves with the spiders and the [ __ ]
bugs and fall asleep nothing wrong with
spiders okay so i'm just not sensitive
i'm more well no i'm not sensitive about
spiders and bugs i'm sensitive about
poop i don't want to be stepping and
pooping and tracking that all over the
carpet because i gotta clean this lay
down in the goddamn mud and [ __ ] make
a nice little [ __ ] thing in my
[ __ ] jacket and fall asleep in the
pouring rain y'all don't know how good
you have it
well like i said i'm not worried about
that i'm more worried about poop
i'm not worried about poop because i
don't like i don't step and poop i don't
want it well that you know of i don't
step in it
i see where i'm going what if you don't
see it i can smell it
i can smell it [ __ ] a mile away oh i
forgot oh i forgot that
that tom's perfect and knows everything
yeah yep that's right thank you david
june thank you i can send you all some
feet picks
i don't want to see
well some people might be into it i
don't know
thank you
thank you zach
agree with tom i love the houses frank
lloyd wright did he's an artistic idol
of mine and i think his life would make
a great show topic honestly like big
open spaces and since
who was i don't think it was you zack
but somebody sent me
the book about that murder that took
place at the frank lloyd wright house at
its house and i didn't actually know
about that like i knew who frank lloyd
wright was obviously and i'd seen like a
lot of his designs and stuff but i
didn't know about that whole murder
situation yeah holy crap that was like
[ __ ] hardcore so probably i'm gonna
write that down too i'm gonna do a show
about that too because man what a good
book that was it's called murder in a
prairie house by the way
i think it's funny you know what i mean
a lot of uh working class and middle
class people they're obsessed especially
the older generations boomers are really
big
into [ __ ] buying some buying a house
and stuffing it filled with filled with
[ __ ] useless possessions
to impress relatives or neighbors that
never come over to your [ __ ] house
anyway
if you look at here in
florida and look at the mansions that
they have here the newer mick mansions
i i i say mcmansions is kind of a
derogatory
but um if you actually look at what's in
those
they're empty they look like hotels
they pick that [ __ ] up out of a damn
catalog
even the furniture comes out of a
catalog
it's kind of like you're walking into a
damn hotel more than a house
the people that own those aren't in
there very much they don't go to most of
those rooms that are in that house
they'll live in a real small apartment
inside that house
and they move from one house to the
other
because they have five of those
ten years later when those things age
out
they demolish them or abandon them
or sell them or abandon them
then they tear them down
they're not even worth any money
it's just not like it was back in the
old days
you would think well what do you mean
it's a 5 million dollar mansion i
challenge you to sell it
no one will buy it
because the mansion game is all real
rich people
and only and rich people only want brand
new mansions that are built to their
specifications they don't want used
mansions
they just don't
so
they move away from a mansion and it
[ __ ] ends up sitting there
and then getting demolished then they
built another mcmansion on it
it's a weird game man
but you go all over youtube
and see people that break into those
abandoned mick mansions
and they videotape them from the inside
that videotape them that's like that's
an old [ __ ] term they'll record the
insides and make a whole like urban
exploration show
of [ __ ] big mansions what's in there
when the house [ __ ] exceeds a million
dollars you almost can't sell it anymore
they're gonna tear it down and build
another one yeah i mean diminishing
return diminishing returns uh mr rabata
says hi jenny tom hi what's up uh is the
house complete meaning uh well the
closing is a lot of shit's gotta do the
16th 16th yeah uh but we have like some
[ __ ] we got the sprinkler system fixed
yeah so there's that uh the guy came
yesterday yeah i'm gonna redecorate that
outside they're [ __ ] i'm gonna get to
do different with the
landscaping the landscaping's [ __ ] up
on this house uh and the paint it's not
terrible but it needs like it needs some
shrubbery on the side i feel like the
side looks kind of uh i'm going to get a
professional in here to [ __ ] get this
[ __ ] looking right uh thank you jeffy
art i wear cowboy boots almost all the
time but always take them off when i get
in the apartment there's a reason
they're called [ __ ] kickers yeah
yeah see i'm just kind of like i don't
know i'm not i don't like wearing shoes
anyway it's very confining uh so i only
put shoes on when i go outside jack
jacqueline listen what jaclyn said man
yeah
that's one of my favorite speeches i've
ever heard tom make i hate a bunch of
stuff in a house too drives me crazy it
drives me [ __ ] crazy oracle says i
don't trust people who don't book cases
full of books i don't either actually uh
and i have actually
i need some more bookcases because i
have like you guys can't see but i have
like these desks that i have
uh these things on they have little
shelves on the side and i have like
piles of books and magazines over there
because i didn't have room to put them
anywhere else i got two shelves over
there i got one shelf over there and i
have books [ __ ] yeah well what i'm
talking about clutter i'm not talking
about bush shelves bookshelves i can
understand that you're talking about
like knickknacks what they call what old
ladies in the [ __ ] boomers called
knickknacks they're gonna put some kind
of a [ __ ]
end table or something and then they're
gonna put a bunch of [ __ ] on the end
table
and then they're gonna have a [ __ ]
couch that nobody sits in and they're
gonna put end tables on these and then
there's gonna be
like all these little [ __ ] tables
little bitty [ __ ] tables everywhere
that don't do anything and you don't
they just hold some kind of decoration i
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
i just hate it i like sleek
i like of empty spaces that you can walk
around in i like things that are useful
technology that
the idea is to
have technology to eliminate things and
to make things more efficient
so you have more space inside your house
that you can actually use
and yeah okay i believe you could have
some furniture but that's furniture that
you use i don't like [ __ ] that you you
don't use the japanese were right about
that if you looked at an ancient would
not be anxious but 1700's japanese house
it was just empty rooms with stuff that
they bring out and they do stuff they
put it back and they didn't have [ __ ]
knick-knacks and [ __ ] little statues
of [ __ ]
everywhere you know and [ __ ]
i don't know i just associated with my
grandparents
you know
i hate it
collector's plates
gran there's hammer posts a quote i'd
heard this quote before actually yeah
rudyard kipling a man can never have too
much wine too many books or too much
ammunition yeah okay
uh thank you zach gave us another super
chat the minimalism movement can be
overkill too yeah i agree major liminal
space vibes from some of them or looks
like an ikea showroom that no one
actually lives in yeah i've seen that as
well i've seen it done where it's just
this massive room and there's like
nothing in it right uh which yeah that's
kind of like defeating the purpose
because it's like all this space that
you're actually not using a modern
florida mansion actually looks like a
business
it has a living quarters in it but the
rest of it just looks like a hotel lobby
but that's fine that's fine that's great
i don't like all that [ __ ] personal
[ __ ]
those houses are mostly businesses
anyway or those mansions are business
running a mansion is like running a
business
ex very similar
so i understand i'm kind of in between i
don't really like i don't
i like some of the real sleek like ultra
modern stuff
uh and some of the real spacious stuff i
like some of that aesthetic
but i also kind of like
uh not the over overly baroque like
cluttered victorian yeah but i like the
look of some of the victorian like i
really like that um you know that kind
of like that wallpaper kind of [ __ ] with
all the like creepy kind of [ __ ] i like
that that only makes that only makes
sense in those houses but i well yeah
but i don't like
a lot of stuff that's like in your way
or stuff that's like unnecessary i don't
have anything against
um you know having things in your house
that are personal to you yeah like you
know as far as
you know tchotchkes or whatever um
you know like a little
thing like you know like a little statue
or whatever i don't you know because i
have some [ __ ] like that and you know
and honestly to me that just seems to
like personalize the space or make it
like make me want to hang out in it
that's one that's just but two rooms
though yeah but i you know it so i kind
of feel like like zach was saying i kind
of feel like the aesthetic can go too
far in the other direction where
everything is just sterile yeah um which
is another place i don't want to hang
out in because it just looks like i'm at
the dentist so it's like i i don't know
i kind of like a happy medium
yeah i guess so well i think
even in a mansion there's the living
quarters and then there's the rest of
the mansion
the rest of the mansion is basically
like a hotel it's kind of sterile
and and it looks right that way because
they're it's modern architecture
you couldn't go in there and make it
victorian unless that house was a real
victorian house
then it makes more sense
yeah i mean honestly if i had all the
money um i would totally do like an old
school like victorian gothic i would got
the [ __ ]
but i wouldn't have like a lot of
clutter because i don't like that either
but you have to build that house that's
what i'm saying yeah if i had the money
i would totally do that because i like
that aesthetic i don't but i don't want
to be tripping over everything either
yeah most of the [ __ ] around here that's
when you look at it if it's a florida
mansion it's pretty modern
so you couldn't do that you couldn't do
the victorian stuff looks like something
out of
well the movies that you see about
florida you know
a miami [ __ ] mansion is kind of like
the archetype
and it's glass and concrete
[ __ ] it has
boats that you can pull your boat up
into a [ __ ] landing instead of
instead of a driveway it's got a [ __ ]
boat it's got it's got a river out in
front not really a river but
a channel out in front of it that gets
you to the ocean and [ __ ] that's where
that's that's the way a lot of them are
jeff bezos pulls up in a damn yacht and
parks it in front of his house you know
they just look real modern but if you go
inside it just looks like a business or
a nightclub in certain areas depends on
the room they have bowling alleys in
them
you know that's what you're talking
about
look at them they're [ __ ]
fantastic thank you mr roboto would you
use all that i wouldn't
but they're all they're all made to
order
so
you know
that's what that dude wants in it
thank you mr roboto tom reminds me of
mickey rourke that's what he said mine
is yeah i've heard that before
zach says
uh to me you'd hard wire the house with
giallo style lights oh yeah i totally
would do that yeah uh i have that hot
pink uh lit living room and dark green
lit bathroom well uh you know what in my
old house which was
quite a
a great deal smaller than this one the
one that i owned in daytona
uh i used suspiria for my
uh
inspiration and pretty much the whole
house was done
in i mean within reason because i didn't
have a lot of money but i did it all in
sort of like yellow colors so like the
living room was like blood red the den
was this kind of like uh like dark blue
the halls were black uh and then all the
doors were black and then they had like
red
i painted these like kind of like art
nouveau like insets on them just like in
suspiria like the doors in the in the
school in suspiria so i painted that on
there and then the kitchen
was hot pink
uh with black
cabinets
and then we had another room in the back
that was like an office that was like a
purple
the bedroom was blue
and then the spare room what the [ __ ]
color was that
i can't remember what color i painted
this bear room maybe that was blue too
or maybe that was green i can't remember
maybe purple i don't know but i painted
it all the time because i really like
saturated
colors i don't like anything i don't
like beige
i don't like any of these kind of like
[ __ ] like faded colors that's that's
[ __ ] oh my goodness thank you tila
thank you so much that's very nice of
you jenny happy new years for all the
hard work you doing for having to put up
with you know who
[Laughter]
just kidding
but not really
love to the best chat beeps oh thank you
so much that's really really nice he
just like he went to the bathroom i
think but uh i'll tell him i'll tell him
when he gets back but yeah so
i mean i honestly i think it came out
nice if i'd had more money because like
i said i couldn't really like afford
tila just sent us a very very nice super
chat oh did she t and she says she just
showed up
she says happy new years for all the
hard work i do and for having to put up
with you thank you you know well she
said you know who but we all know
about me
[Laughter]
honestly like i said i like
if you're gonna paint a room
paint a [ __ ] room don't just do this
oh it's beige it's eggshell yeah to me
that just seems like would why even
paint it no it just seems like it's not
even a color well they're doing that
because they can resell the house
without i know but it's just kind of
like if you're gonna have a color have a
[ __ ] color make a statement yeah you
know what i'm saying so
you know those which is why i painted
this room black tila's just jumping in
now yeah she's just jumping up late and
just throwing a [ __ ] all these
bills all this money and honestly like
the you can't see it but my dressing
room and my bathroom in there i did
those in a whole um
art nouveau
alphonse musha theme
so i painted them like absinthe green
and i have like all like alphonse musha
i even have an alphonse moosha um
shower curtain
i got that on amazon it took like
forever to get here i was so excited
when i got it but yeah so because i've
always liked loved his artwork i love
all that art nouveau [ __ ] so
yeah i did a whole i did a whole art
nouveau thing in there honestly one of
these days you know what i'd like to do
with one of the rooms in this house
i want to do a whole
lovecraft slash cthulhu theme
i want to do like a the wall i want to
do like an ocean kind of like ombre kind
of look where it's like dark blue to
light blue or teal or something and then
put all kind of like [ __ ]
lovecraft and like octopus [ __ ] all over
it i'd love that
but you know that's that's just me
that's what i would do i'm gonna get
pokey pants up on the show are you gonna
get pookie on the show somebody asked us
about
pookie in beijing where did it go
how long you had pookie in beijing and
why the pet names
pookie we have had
she is
four and a half yeah beige is uh over 10
years she's 12 years old beige is 12 or
13. so you had beijing before i even met
you yeah
i mean she was she was kind of little
like when we first started like hanging
out she's in good shape though yeah you
wouldn't know she's still very very
playful yeah
um
pookie
we got her
in
i think the summer of 2007.
yeah
yeah when she was like a baby still she
was a kitten
and so we've had her for a year
yeah
like apparently like some like friend of
your moms had like found her or that's
what this story was yeah i wouldn't
believe it i i don't believe it either
but i'm just saying but that's what the
story was um yeah oh i found her in my
backyard and like a dog was attacking
her yeah bit her tail off and which is
dumb because we found out later that
she's probably she's a man she's a man
she had a tail it was a brazilian friend
of ours and brazilian women that are
trying to make money tell stories
i grew up in brazil i know all about it
tried to tell it and then she
thought it was a male cat and named it
and [ __ ] you know and she and as soon
as we got her
tom's like that's a female cat female
cat
yeah
i mean it's hard to tell when they're
kittens but the way because they're you
know you have to look at their butt and
everything but the way she was acting
like i'm pretty sure that's a female cat
yeah and it turned out
yeah that was a female cat so
she tried to make up an exciting story
to get me to take the cat but she but we
were going to take her anyway because as
soon as she sent the picture i was just
kind of like oh we're having that kitten
because
how cute she was she i mean she was so
little i have a video of her somewhere
like the day or she was the size of a
baseball she was tiny tiny yeah and she
had this big blue eyes i mean her eyes
are gold now but all kittens eyes are
blue which i didn't actually know until
recently
um all of their eyes are blue until they
grow into whatever eye color they have
so she had like
blue eyes when we got her and she was
tiny tiny tiny
and the woman that had her
was she had a bunch of dogs so i guess
she was just keeping pookie
in a cage in the garage in the garage
in [ __ ] july yeah
i said we gotta get the cat yeah and i
mean like i said as soon as i saw the
picture i'm like yeah we're having i
mean we've been talking about getting a
kitten anyway yeah
so
we're like yeah we'll take her and so
she brought her over and like seriously
that night pookie was just kind of like
oh you're my new parents okay
look i got to start making uh food well
i was going to like try and finish the
finished story okay that's all i was
going to say i don't know if you're done
or not yeah well okay oh now you ask
okay
i mean i was almost done okay so uh so
yeah so one of the things that i wanted
to say before we wrap it up is that
recently another
what oh we got another one oh okay oh
i'm behind where am i going thank you mr
roboto you should probably do a goth
theme on a budget yeah it's hard to do
though i mean some of this i have like
expensive tastes i guess um some of the
stuff i really like i'm like oh i really
like that but it's like so expensive you
know what i mean all the stuff that you
can get for cheap like doesn't really
look that yeah good
so uh yeah it's kind of a shame i mean i
should probably like learn to make my
own stuff then that would probably solve
a lot of problems but um yeah so uh
recently a book came out because like i
said the lindbergh case it's kind of
you know everybody kind of has their own
theories about it but this one actually
kind of sounds like maybe there's
something to it like i said it's not
crazy
um
but thank you zach was watching some
hammer movies seems like the colorful
lighting in those influence the giallo
movies i love movies with real vibrant
aesthetics yeah i do as well and
honestly like all that all that [ __ ]
from like hammer movies if i could live
in a house from a hamburger movie i
totally would we have lots of color we
got smart lighting and laser beams and
[ __ ] that's always like you go out go
out in the living room right now it
looks like a damn
nightclub well that's why i mean the
lighting in here
i just really like all the kind of like
primary color lighting i don't ever turn
lights on in here other than these
lights got rgbs and bliss lights that
[ __ ] project galaxies and nebulas and
at night it looks quite exciting in here
just gotta um
more super chats everybody's [ __ ]
throwing the money our way that's great
thank you victor done i thought y'all
were just starting uh we've been we've
been going on for hours well only two
and a half hours which is actually kind
of short for us yeah yeah to be honest
with you because i kept my mouth shut
did you yeah i don't remember that
happening
see this is how she does she's always
trying to spin [ __ ] around but he's
pretending like he hasn't like talked to
talk to talk talk
he's pretending he's been too much no i
haven't i drank less than you actually
but i just it's just about the same
it's just really funny how you're trying
to like he's trying to gaslight me you
guys like into like yeah yeah yeah go
back and watch
oh yeah i gotta go watch it i just sit
there and sat there
let you do the show yeah but then you
would talk and go on and on and on for a
really long time like some other like
three times
yeah but for how long each time that's
the that's a big quick just a couple
minutes yeah you gotta understand how a
couple minutes if i take like a minute
you think it's an hour
maybe it just seems though it just seems
that way because how you are aaron's
laughing tom's saying jenny drank too
much and she's laughing
and taylor said tom kept his mouth shut
y'all no he did it yeah i did you know
that's not gonna happen [ __ ] you [ __ ]
get all these women [ __ ] ganging up
on me we're not ganging up on you we're
just telling the truth you just don't
like it oscar says uh oh yeah okay i
meant to tell you to cook the thief his
wife and her lover i was gonna do that
show on the next matinee and then i
looked it up the only [ __ ] place that
you can stream this [ __ ] is on sling
and to what like normally you can watch
some [ __ ] on sling for free like on
pluto but you can only watch that movie
if you bought the epics add-on
uh which
we don't have
so
i might have to like order the blu-ray
or dvd because i do actually want to do
a review of that and i want to see it
again if you send her the dvd we'll do
it or i'll get if i can find it cheap
then i'll buy it because i do actually
want to do it and i want to see it again
but i was like mad because that was the
only streaming service that offered it
and i'm like [ __ ] man we don't have that
and i can't afford another [ __ ]
streaming service
i already got amazon and hulu and
shutter and [ __ ]
netflix and what the [ __ ] else we got a
bunch of other [ __ ] too so you know
um but yeah so this last one that i want
to talk about
uh this was kind of like a book that
came out sort of recently and even
though
okay you know how the black dahlia thing
and then there was like that dude that
wrote the book about oh i think my dad
killed the black dahlia oh and also by
the way he was the zodiac um
i kind of feel like even though this is
sort of the same situation where it was
kind of like a guy that
thinks his dad i don't think he
he didn't say his dad was like one of
the kidnappers but his dad like knew the
kidnappers so it's kind of that but i
don't
i think he i think he might be on to
something
so this guy named robert zorn wrote this
book called cemetery john
uh the undiscovered mastermind of the
lindbergh kidnapping
now he says that the person that
dr
condon
met up with in the cemetery one of the
kidnappers was actually not bruno
hautman because if you mat if you
remember what i said
uh you know dr condon initially
did not identify hautman as the person
that he had talked to in the cemetery
um you know he wasn't willing to he
identified him at the trial
but he wasn't willing to identify him
when he got arrested
so yeah and honestly i have to say that
like the sketch
kind of looks like him but kind of not
but
what they found out later so this guy
robert zorn he's like okay my um i think
that the person that
that court that condon actually met with
in the cemetery was this other german
guy named john knoll who was an
associate he's not saying bruno hatman
was innocent he was saying they were
working together but this was like
another associate so he's saying this is
like john knoll right now he says when i
was a kid my dad whose name was eugene
um he says that we had a neighbor
named john
and this neighbor took him to some
amusement park in new jersey in 1931
which is about nine months before the
kidnapping
and he says that the neighbor and two
other guys were talking and he overheard
them and they were speaking german but
he said he understood some of the words
some of the words that he heard were
bruno
bruno hotman even though that wasn't the
name that he usually went by he went
usually went by his middle name which is
richard and englewood which was where
uh
lindbergh's parents lived
so
there was that so he remembered it but
like years later so he said he thought
that maybe these guys were like talking
about the kidnapping or like planning it
or whatever
so
he was reading an article about the
kidnapping in the 60s and it triggered
his memory so he kind of like started
looking back into it
so
i will say
that there's like other evidence too but
that i saw a picture of john knoll the
guy that we're talking about who they
think was one of maybe bruno hautman's
associates
that dude um you know how sometimes they
show you like the police sketch and
you're like how the [ __ ] did they even
ever catch the guy like with that police
sketch doesn't look anything like him
the police sketch
and the picture of john knoll
look
almost
identical i have to say
john knoll looks exactly
like that [ __ ] police sketch
so
i'm not saying that that means that he
was involved but
he it really does look a lot like him
uh also remember how i said like the
handwriting analysis was kind of
inconclusive over whether berna hautman
had written the uh the notes or not
but uh john knowles handwriting actually
looks a lot more like the handwriting
on the notes than hautman's did and john
knoll was german was a german immigrant
as well so the same [ __ ] that was uh
applied for bruno hauteman would apply
for him as well
um
they apparently and i didn't find out
about this until later but apparently
some of the ransom bills that were spent
had uh traces of animal fat on them
uh john knoll was a
deli worker uh so that would explain
that he's recommended a movie called
nightwing
oh i remember that one yeah sounds
familiar i haven't seen that in a long
time yeah it's like that the best of the
bat movie i haven't seen that in a
really long time yeah i saw that on
cable back in the whole yeah that might
be on amazon prime we'll check that out
nightwing
i think i saw it
it just sounds familiar
there were a lot of killer bat movies in
the 70s there was one that was on mst it
might have a different title but i think
what the [ __ ] did they call it like the
mst version was called
it lives by night or something like that
but i think it was also maybe was it
called the bat people
i don't know and i know it had like two
titles
that was also like this a very very 70s
movie but
nightwing is another yeah we should
probably watch that
we'll check it out because i haven't
seen that since i was a kid that goes
along with our 70s [ __ ]
yeah we've been on a 70s kick lately 70s
movies are good
well there's something like well like i
said there's something like really
nostalgic but even if they're not good
there's something like nostalgic about
them
i kind of love all those nature run of
muck movies i love all those disaster
movies that came out in the 70s it's
just there's something really like
comforting about them 70s tone i don't
know why plus everyone had like horrible
horrible clothes there's a simpler
haircut haircuts and yeah you know what
i mean there was something kind of
subversively sexy about them
kind of dirty about them i liked them
well it was almost kind of like watching
low-key porn i guess it was [ __ ]
[Laughter]
likes [ __ ] things i love it but uh but
yeah oh so there was another thing too
well let me get to like he's just going
off on [ __ ] yeah
like what like i said why do i even
bother why do i bother having a towel go
ahead go ahead no go ahead why do i
bother there was just one more thing i
wanted to say there was another thing
too about john noll
one thing
that condon said apparently in the
initial police report when he said that
he met up with the kidnapper
he said that the dude had something
wrong with his thumb like his thumb was
like deformed or he had some kind of
weird growth on it um he didn't bring
that up again as far as i'm aware
now one thing that john knoll did have
was he kind of had like some weird
[ __ ] up like fleshy growth like on his
thumb
which you can kind of see there's like a
picture of him where he's like holding
the kid and you can kind of see that his
thumbs are kind of [ __ ] up or they're
like too big for his hands or some [ __ ]
like that so we kind of had so so a lot
of people have pointed this it's like oh
well that definitively and like i said i
will say i'm not saying that john knoll
was involved i'm not saying but i do
think that there is sufficient evidence
to think
i don't think bruno hautman was innocent
you know so i'm not saying it was some
big miscarriage of justice that he got
electrocuted
i do think he was involved but i think
there were other people involved that
never got caught
i definitely think there was somebody on
the lindbergh family staff
that told the kidnappers
with the deal like where the baby's room
was and when the family was gonna be
there
so i definitely think that probably that
violet sharp chick
and i think that bruno hauptman had at
least one other confederate maybe two
um
because this seems to me this seemed
more like an organized
gang type of thing rather than just like
a one dude doing the [ __ ] type of thing
and honestly most of the evidence and
honestly when i watched the like the pbs
uh the documentary that was on nova
which came out a few years ago they had
uh what's his face uh john douglas on
there that like [ __ ] fbi profiler
and at the end of the thing he thought
he was like pretty much thought the same
thing he's like i don't know who the
other people were but he's like i think
it's very unlikely that this person he's
like i'm not saying bruno happened was
innocent i don't think he was i think he
did it i think he was in on it
but he's like i think that he had
help i think there was just like one or
two people and somebody that worked
inside the house that
probably helped them out or gave them
information and that's kind of where i'm
at as well
um
i don't think he was innocent at all but
i definitely think that there were other
people that were not
prosecuted yeah either
just because they didn't have enough
evidence or they didn't bother or you
know oh they're like oh we got the guy
we killed him it's over
you know so maybe they didn't really
pursue pursue it any further some of the
[ __ ] that's crazy i don't think that
charles lindbergh necessarily had
anything to do with
doing the [ __ ] with his own kid i think
that's
again possible but it seems a little out
there
um but
you know the [ __ ] about help and having
help that's not out there
tina says she i saw the attic too said
it was a weird freaking movie
[Music]
i remembered it you know i haven't seen
it in a long time but i remember liking
it
kind of had this older woman who
just weird you know what i mean
she's kind of cute
but she's kind of regressive it's like
she's a teenager she's like a 50 year
old teenager
and then you find out this weird [ __ ]
that had to hurt her dad's keeping her
under his thumb
and the [ __ ] she got stood up at the
damn altar
and then you find out oh man i can't
spoil it it's called the attic it's real
good
it's pretty i need to re i need to watch
that because i don't think as it unfolds
and [ __ ]
but like i said i said to you i haven't
seen it in a long time so last time i
saw it might have been 97 98
so i don't know how i'd react to it now
but i liked it back then
david june says watching things from the
70s definitely makes you filthier oh
yeah well it should
aaron says anyone watching yellow
jackets i'm hooked everybody's talking
about that i really should see it yeah
yeah
it's a series okay captain bleuerto says
did not see it but an early 70s horror
movie from florida called zat it's an ed
wood kind of movie i've seen it uh it
was on mystery science theater except it
was called blood waters of dr z
and it was filmed in florida and it's
terrible it's basically about a schlumpy
scientist
uh with a comb over
who
makes a potion
to turn himself into
a sea monster
kind of like a really really low budget
creature from the black lagoon situation
why would you want to do that i don't
know but it's
it's bad but it's i mean the mst episode
is fun though but it's called blood
waters of dr z on there but it's the
same movie so yeah it was shot in
florida the funniest thing about it is
that
there's some scenes in there with an
alligator
where they're definitely definitely
trying to make you think that it's like
a swamp or some [ __ ] but it's clearly a
swimming pool i mean
clearly they're not even really trying
to hide it all that much and it's just
like it's just very very funny mango
says have you seen the nicholas cage
film pig i haven't but i've been that's
good i've been meaning to watch it
because it's on
hulu it's on hulu now i think it's on
hulu okay because because the uh uh
the trailers look good yeah it's on hulu
already yeah [ __ ]
i was gonna tell you because i was like
yeah i just saw it when i was looking
scrolling through i think i'm pretty
sure it's hulu i'd almost rather pay a
few bucks for it if we could well you
can but well i pay for hulu okay that
shit's eight dollars a month oh is it
okay
we used to be 689 but it went up today
nicholas cage's career all right just so
he continues to do some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
although the best things that he's done
recently is mandy i'm gonna say you know
mandy color out of space was pretty good
too i want to see that one again we have
it on blu-ray
god damn it you're making me want to
watch wild at heart again the david
lynch movie with nicholas cajun yeah
this here is just nick's changing the
[ __ ] out
[Laughter]
and then the one where he was fighting
all the damn animatronic [ __ ] willy's
wonderland willie's wonderland was good
also i think that's also on hulu yeah
yeah we saw that though but yeah i'm
sure pretty sure pig is honestly kind of
guy
yeah because we've seen some [ __ ] that
he was in that
it's ridiculous it's just like oh
well
we watched
uh they put on shutter they put one of
his newer movies which is what was it
called
incident from a ghost land or yeah which
wasn't any good which
i get what they were going for i didn't
love it though it was it was basically a
rip off of into the badlands it was kind
of which i didn't like that one
no i wasn't a big fan of that either but
it looked cool but i just did i got to a
point where just like yeah everything
looks cool but i don't really care yeah
it was it was that kind of situation and
it was like hard for me to sit through
like i could understand like how some
people would really dig it but i just
couldn't i couldn't get into it
but nicolas cage was like the best part
about it that and like the whole
aesthetic what the [ __ ] is that movie
called best nicholas cage movie in
modern [ __ ] memory
is mandy it just is
that [ __ ] worked mandy was so [ __ ]
good and that [ __ ] worked i loved that
movie colorado space was good too but i
kind of feel like that was a little more
of like a mixed reaction which i get
yeah you know what i mean because that
was a little it didn't work as well as
mandy it was all right it didn't but it
was still pretty good yeah well i think
the thing with colorado's base even
though it was like fairly accurate to
the story but it was tonally it was a
little strange
i kind of feel like they were trying to
do like the whole love crafty thing but
then they were doing like a weird black
comedy thing too and i'm not really
entirely sure that it gelled yeah t she
loves vampires kiss i haven't seen it in
a long time
yeah
not one time
i was doing like some [ __ ] so i was
doing some nicholas cage [ __ ] but yeah
um vampire's kiss you should probably
see that gotta see pig
he ate a cockroach in it did he yes it's
still early we could see pig tonight
yeah i kept meaning to tell you i can't
believe i forgot to tell you but i was
scrolling through hulu the other day and
i was like oh they have pig we should
totally watch that because i've heard a
lot about that yeah i'm pretty sure it's
on hold i'll tell you what show's over
if you can get me out of here and i'll
start cooking we'll watch pig
okay what are you gonna cook
well i thought i'd make some of that uh
crab salad okay with a cake that's right
you mentioned that yeah i gotta make
sure that i have that uh
bay seasoning old bay are you gonna put
old bay in it you gotta put danny dill
in there
i could do that put some do you want old
bay and dill or just dill well i don't
know but that really good usually it's
old bay yeah that's true and mayonnaise
and uh lemon
and then um
i was gonna like serve that
i have a bunch of damn
coleslaw mix that i have to get rid of i
was gonna toss that like a salad oh okay
so we'll have like a crab salad salad
maybe maybe i'll toss that
toss that coleslaw mix in italian
dressing
okay and have some crab salad on the
side as a protein either one like i mean
i like to serve it on toast i like yeah
i like crab salad like on a sandwich i
don't think i have any pita i think i
think i'm out of pita we don't have any
bread
just toast that's okay white toast
would you what do you want you want you
would you rather have it on toast yeah
you really have an auto sorry yeah
oh yeah jason well he said prisoners of
the ghost land that's the movie we were
talking about yeah yeah it was it was
all right i didn't love it i didn't love
it i i wanted to like it more than but i
couldn't really get it it was like too
much like a made for tv movie
mango says look up the unbearable weight
of massive talent nicholas cage's new
movie it looks great really the
unbearable weight of it oh my god that's
an awesome it says like the american is
that like the unbearable lightness of
being i know
is that what they're making fun of
here's the deal
laugh that's a deep cut laugh if you all
will i can understand the pain
of the of carrying around the burden of
having so much talent i understand that
i can i can i can i can feel it how do
you understand that because of all the
talent
[Laughter]
i'm such an [ __ ] i [ __ ] understand
it you think i would understand that i
understand it totally okay good i don't
know how you do but okay
[Laughter]
mega says you could always have a bacon
sandwich while watching pigs see that
would like work out i got look i go to
sam's and buy whole packs already made
bacon bits those [ __ ] are good man i
sprinkle them in omelets
he puts bacon bits in everything bacon
bits in those things even even places
where bacon bits do not belong
that's not true
bacon belongs everywhere
bacon blocks everywhere yeah man there's
another shirt bacon belongs everywhere
i'll sprinkle them on top of the [ __ ]
hamburger as the [ __ ] cheeses
mountain
oh yeah you know what belongs on a
hamburger a fried egg they put guacamole
on that [ __ ] a fried egg belongs in a
hamburger then that's your friends on it
you do that in brazil
what
a fried egg a hamburger on a
cheeseburger well people do it here too
they got that [ __ ] from south america
that's good i mean honestly more things
need to have fried eggs on them yeah i
love fried eggs yeah i used to just eat
that for dinner when i was poor because
[ __ ] eggs are cheap right so you just
fry up a couple eggs that was like
[ __ ] mango says that nick cage is
playing himself in that film
well there you go yeah
all right then i'm gonna let you shut it
down jenny i'm gonna go all right we'll
start
so i actually did mostly
get this case discussed you gotta
discuss we're talking about is over
right yeah yeah you gotta discuss all
right
i just you know she's blaming me for
getting into i know i wasn't you're just
you're projecting again
i just know how you are he's like
wandering off all right well no i was i
was actually like talking to myself like
did i cover all of it okay i think i
covered everything i needed all right
all right y'all i'll see you guys
looking friday he's gonna go make
something i'll see you now i'll see you
before friday because we're gonna no
friday no because we have to fry okay
tomorrow thursday yesterday we got
tomorrow off and i'll see you all friday
i mean tomorrow we might go to the
movies yeah
or something we need to go see spiderman
he wants to go see spiderman
all right so thank you guys for dropping
by thanks you for all the really nice
super chats that was very generous of
you this evening we'll be back friday
night for our side track show in which
tom will probably be happy because he'll
be able to talk about whatever uh so you
know uh but yeah we'll see you guys
again friday night have a good rest of
your evening have a good day tomorrow
and we will see you guys on friday night